So, exzellent, exzellent, da bin ich Leute, auf gehts, ich mach mal die Pool Sounds kurz
wieder aus, ansonsten muss ich aufs Klo, ja das aktuelle Pool Meter müssen wir ausnutzen,
Josef T, dankeschön für den Sub, ist das Josef, Josef T, wahrscheinlich der T vom Josef,
tja, übrigens, 20 Subs, Snapchat, oder waren es 10 Subs, schon wieder vergessen, ah nee,
10 Subs, Snapchat, Snap, Snapchat, Leute, hast du gesehen, dass gestern mal Leute im Voice
waren, ja, also 10 Subs, Snapchat, 20 Subs, Oberteil wechseln, 50 Subs, Game Attack auf
den Oberschenkel, 100 Subs, passt mal auf, 100 Subs, Resitas Cosplay, muss man diese
Subgoals noch irgendwie auferleihen, ich glaub mal, ich glaub man muss die Sub, man
muss die Sub noch auferleihen, oder, es kosten 20 Subs, 100 Euro, ich hab nicht gesagt, dass
es finish wird, Funküchle, Twitch Prime, dankeschön für den Sub, oder die Subgoals,
die Subgoals müssen da noch hin, Moment, Moment, so, wie macht man das jetzt so, wow,
viel zu, viel zu fett, so, excellent, excellent, sieht das jetzt aus, passt das so, ah nee,
das ist weiß, das erkennt man nicht, das erkennt man nicht, Moment, Moment, Moment, die Subgoals,
das ist das wichtigste, die Subgoals muss man sehen, sonst macht es ja keiner, äh,
Black, ah, yes, Outline, kann das ein Outline, Outline, wow, wow, huge, massive, so, machen
wir das jetzt, jetzt ist das Profi Stream, oder, also jetzt, jetzt, jetzt kann nichts
mehr schiefgehen, wenn auch Name auf den Kopf, selbstverständlich, ja, was meinst du denn,
wir machen hier volles Programm, Alter, Moment, Moment, ich hab für den Stream, ich hab den
Stream jetzt relativ spontan angemacht, weil ich dieses blöde, dieses blöde Keks im Poolbild
gebaut hab, ja, außerdem, außerdem, die müssen ja gar kein Content machen, also die
machen ja auch kein Content so wirklich, die sitzen auch nur im Pool, aber jetzt, jetzt
mal hier, KekWade, mal ernsthaft, ich wollte ein paar Stellen anzeigen, zusammen uns angucken,
ob wir was für ein Stream finden, äh, nicht für ein Stream, fürs nächste Video finden,
äh, Flowmania, danke für den Sub, 10 auf Verlänger, das zählt auch, ja, ja, zählt
auch, also, also, damit ist natürlich gemeint, ne, wenn ihr das hier oben seht, es muss EINER
10 Subs giften für Snapchat, ich hab überhaupt kein Snapchat-Account, by the way, ich hab
auch nicht gesagt Snapchat von mir, was, was sagst du dazu, was ist das, was, was gegen,
äh, was ist das, wo ist denn Herrnan, Herrnan, ja gut, wie stellen die sich das vor, wie
möchtest du denn jemanden dazu zwingen, einen Schnelltest zu machen, zwangsweise in die
Nasramen oder was, das funktioniert nicht, du kannst da keinen zu zwingen, außerdem
ist das illegal Leute, zu solchen Dingen zu zwingen, wo kommen wir denn dahin, das wird
sich, das wird sich auf keinen Fall durchsetzen lassen, sie befürchten aus, äh, ey, das
ist gar nicht mal, das ist gar nicht so weit her geholt, ne, aktuell wird das ja, aktuell
wird das ja, ähm, nicht unbedingt, sondern nicht anonym gemacht, wie auch, ja, so unrecht
haben die, ey, ich muss sagen, so unrecht haben die gar nicht, ich mein, das ist natürlich
vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber, das die Eltern am Bedenken haben, kann ich
verstehen, ja, ich, mir, ich hab aber leider keine bessere Idee, ne, das ist so, das ist
so, aber ich hab, ich hab leider auch keine wirklich bessere Idee, Striker95, dankeschön
für den Tiermonster, NilsFPS, sieben Monate, huge IQ, Massive, geht ja hier wahnsinnig,
plus plus IQ, was mit dem Hype Train los, nur weil ich im Pool bin oder was, Moment
Leute, ich mach euch, ich mach euch die Pool Sounds noch mal an, in der Hoffnung, ihr
müsst nicht alle aufs Klo, was hab ich, hab ich, glaub ich jetzt was übersehen, hab
ich schon alle, Erbsenhirn, Prime Gaming, dankeschön für den Zapp, euch zahle ich
schon, BlackHat19, danke, huge Subscription, der Scam funktioniert, ja, also ist das einfach,
das ist 0W, alter, 0W, Marabona518, dankeschön, Prime Subscription, Jobsuche im Pool, der
Titel scheint auch zu sehen, übrigens, die schlechteste Seite, um Jobs zu suchen, ernsthaft,
also, das, also was heißt die schlechteste Seite, schlechteste Seite stimmt nicht, da
sind die lustigsten, da sind die lustigsten Angebote, bis jetzt hab ich da zumindest die
lustigsten Angebote gefunden, übrigens, by the way, soll ich euch mal die eine der
ansprechendsten Stellenanzeigen zeigen, aus letzter Zeit, hab ich euch gestern im Stream
schon gezeigt, Leute, wer möchte nicht der neue Computerfuzzi werden, von Rolf, wir machen
das Fenster, ich finde, das ist voll ein Land, auf gehts Computerfuzzi, du bist auch, was,
du bist auch auf der Suche, im Cloud und DevOps Bereich, ja, ist ja auch was, wo viele Leute
was suchen, ne, Leute, ich hab heute übrigens mit mir gerungen, ich sag's euch, ich hab
mit mir gerungen, ich mein, das kommt ja nicht von ungefähr, dass ich jetzt so einen blöden
Tool hier reingemacht hab, ich hab mit mir gerungen, soll ich ein Video zu dem Thema
machen oder nicht, das Problem ist, ich hab mal ein Video gemacht, 2014 oder so, als
die ganze Boopcam-Streaming-Thematik so angesagt war, ich hab da mal ein Video zugemacht, 2014
und ich muss sagen, so, ich hab das einfach so, Aufnahme gedrückt und einfach losgelabert,
ja, ich glaube, für manche Aussagen in dem Video damals, hätten sie mich heute geflamt,
aber, das Problem ist gerade an der Sache, du kannst dich zu diesem Thema, du kannst
dich zu solchen Themen eigentlich gar nicht wirklich mehr äußern, ohne, dass es ein
riesen Geflame gibt, das geht mittlerweile nicht anders, weil es fühlt sich sofort
in der Ultra angegriffen, wenn einer was sagt, was ihm nicht 100% nicht passt, ich hab auch
schon gedacht, ich ignorier das eigentlich, nee, ich glaube, ich glaube, ich glaube,
ich mach das nicht, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, also, Drakkoin, Dankeschön für
den Sub, FlickGP, also der IQ geht ja gerade durch die Decke vom Chat hier, ich muss
öfters Pool, ich muss öfters Pool Streams machen, ich seh schon, äh, da sag ich gleich
was zu, ähm, wenn wir gerade beim Thema sind, ich kann mich ja hier mal zum Thema Pool
Streams auslassen, aber erstmal, warum hast du ein Stadia Bild in deinem Memebot, das
ist ganz einfach, dass ich Stadia einblenden kann und dann, mal kurz lachen über Stadia
und dann ist gut, Audio-Quali ist schlecht, ah, Moment, Teams hat wieder umgestellt, alul,
Teams hat wieder umgestellt, alter Teams, jetzt ist besser, oder, jetzt ist besser, stimmt's,
Teams hat mal wieder reingesackt, also, ähm, ich wollte hier noch gerade was dazu sagen,
warte mal, warte mal, warte mal, warte mal, warte mal, äh, kannst du, kannst du mal uns
erklären, was die ganzen Stellenbeschreibungen heißen, keine Stellen, äh, ja, genau, das
ist eine gute Frage, und zwar, es ist unglaublich selten, wenn man, wenn man sich Stellenanzeigen
anguckt, und zwar ist es unglaublich selten, dass man sowas hier sieht, das ist wirklich
selten, die meisten Leute suchen eigentlich kein Fachinformatiker Systemintegration,
das einzige, wo du Fachinformatiker Systemintegration liest, ist, wenn du eine Ausbildungsstelle
suchst, ja, also nach dem Motto, hier, Fachinformatiker Anwendungsentwicklung, äh, Systemintegration
oder wie heißen die, neue, es gibt jetzt, es gibt jetzt neue Fachinformatiker Richtungen,
äh, ich weiß nicht, inwieweit die beliebt sind, genau, es gibt jetzt noch Fachinformatiker
Daten- und Prozessanalyse und Fachinformatiker digitale Vernetzung, ja, die IHK, die muss
öfters mal, bäm, bäm, bäm, die muss, die muss öfters mal was Neues machen, äh, chat,
ihr müsst Ed Wupplos dabei schreiben, wenn ich, wenn ich sehen soll, weil, ich, es wird
grad relativ, ist grad recht viel los, ja, und ich weiß nicht, wie gut das geht, aber
der Grund, warum das in keiner Stellenanzeige drin ist, ist ganz einfach, weil Fachinformatiker
Systemintegration keine wirkliche Stelle ist, die irgendjemand sucht, die Leute suchen dann,
das weiß ich, einen Cloud-Architekt, einen, ähm, Active Directory-Administrator, äh,
Linux-Administrator, einen DevOps-Engineer, was auch immer, die suchen eigentlich kein
Fachinformatiker Systemintegration, das heißt, auch im Umkehrschluss, dass man sich nicht
drauf ausruhen kann, dass man Fachinformatiker Systemintegration ist, weil, also, zumindest
meiner Meinung nach, es sagt jetzt die IHK-Abschlussprüfung nur aus, dass man's geschafft hat und nicht,
dass man wirklich was kann, weil, mal ernsthaft, Leute, mal, mal so eine Frage an euch, ähm,
wie viele Leute im Chat haben wir die Fachinformatiker gelernt haben?
Wir haben bestimmt ordentlich, wollen wir mal ne Umfrage machen, haben wir, Mod-Check,
Mod-Check, Moment, Moment, Mod-Check, Mod-Check, wobei, es reicht schon, reicht schon, reicht
schon, wir haben eigentlich schon genug, haben wir kein Mod-Check mehr, ähm, also, wir haben
ziemlich viele, und, ähm, ich weiß nicht, wie ihr das seht, ich kann das nur aus meiner
Sicht sagen, ich mein, ich hab ja auch Fachinformatiker Systemintegration gelernt, und die IHK-Prüfung
und generell dieses Handling von der IHK ist halt ein Witz, ähm, also sprich, das Einzige,
was die IHK-Abschlussprüfung sagt, ist, dass du gut IHK-Abschlussprüfung machen kannst,
das sagt nicht aus, dass du irgendwas kannst, würde mich mal interessieren, ob ihr das
ähnlich seht, also meiner Meinung nach ist das so, das sagt, ehrlich gesagt, ähm, nicht,
nicht viel, ja, ehrlich gesagt, ich bin der Meinung, ähm, ich würde ja übrigens gerne
mal ne IHK-Abschlussprüfung mit euch zusammen machen, damit die Dinger sind copyrighted,
mal gucken, ob's da mittlerweile, mittlerweile eine gibt, Tests oder so, gibt's da ne Test,
Testprüfung oder irgendwie sowas, wie man öffentlich machen kann, also die Dinger sind
ja alle copyrighted, so, also ich bin der Meinung, jemand, der nicht Fachinformatiker Systemintegration
lernt, drei Jahre in nem Betrieb, oder zweieinhalb, oder drei, was auch immer, äh, Jahre in
nem Betrieb, sondern, der sich einfach nur ein halbes Jahr auf die Fachinformatiker IHK-Prüfung
vorbereitet, der hat ne bessere Abschlussprüfung, als jemand, der das drei Jahre gelernt hat,
äh, äh, Giant Master, das bringt nichts, ich weiß selbst, wo's die Abschlussprüfung
gibt, aber, äh, ich kann sie nicht zeigen, also jemand, der ein halbes Jahr Abschlussprüfung
lernt für die IHK, hat ne bessere Abschlussprüfung, als jemand, der, die, der den Beruf wirklich
gelernt hat, das heißt, du kannst dich auch überhaupt nicht drauf ausruhen, dass du Fachinformatiker
Systemintegration bist, sondern, äh, du musst halt auch was können, ja, und ich, mir fällt
kein Beruf ein, der so unterschiedlich sein kann, von dem, wo man am Ende landet.
Übrigens, wer's noch nicht gesehen hat, ich hab mal vor ner Weile nen Video mit jemand
gemacht auf YouTube, nämlich, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, das da, falls ihr das noch
nicht gesehen habt, ich, ich hab's, ich hab's ja mal kurz gepostet, ich hab mit ihm zusammen
ein Video aufgenommen, mit dem Noel, vermute ich mal, ich hab ihn eigentlich gar nicht
gefragt, wie man den Vornamen ausspricht, fällt mir grad auf, lul, ähm, bei ihm auf
dem Channel aufgenommen, wo wir uns ein bisschen über die Ausbildung Fachinformatiker Systemintegration
äh, ausgelassen haben, hat auch relativ viele Aufrufe gekriegt, und, ähm, ich finde, da
sind ein paar ganz interessante Geschichten drin, also, zumindest, du kannst dich im Endeffekt
nicht drauf ausruhen, denn, dass, wenn du Fachinformatiker Systemintegration gelernt
hast, das heißt wirklich, du kannst echt nur die Basics, wir haben ja gelernt, auf YouTube
im letzten Jahr Basics zu können, oder, Basics, ich kann das nicht so schön aussprechen,
ist wichtig, aber in dem Fall bringt's dir nicht allzu viel, zumal, ähm, das ja gar
nicht mal irgendwie heißt, dass du auch was in dem Bereich kannst, was die suchen.
Das kann von, ich kann Druckerpatronen tauschen, zu, ich kann Webanwendung programmieren sein,
es kann einfach alles sein, tja, die, die Basics, ich kann, ich kann, ich kann leider
kein KLS-Dialekt, gibt aber auch ein schlimmeres, letztens wurde mir, Leute, mir wurde letztens
ein Video wieder empfohlen, ich weiß nicht, was YouTube hat, der Kell ist glaube ich schon
seit Jahren aus den Trends, aber YouTube ist der Meinung ab und an, empfehlen sie mir
ein KLS-Video, das ist so eine billige Verkaufsveranstaltung, mir ist absolut schleierhaft, wie da überhaupt
irgendjemand drauf reinfallen kann, das ist einfach nur, das kommst dir vor wie im Teleshopping-Kanal
von, von 1995 und, also, das, das kann er echt nicht verstehen und was ich lustig finde
ist, er scheint sich ja mittlerweile bewusst zu sein, dass er so ein bisschen, äh, gemimt
wird, ja, oder dass er so ein bisschen Miem ist, weil er selbst so Sachen im Titel jetzt
schreibt, die witzigerweise dann, rein dadurch, dass irgendwie so was im Titel steht, einfach
zehnmal mehr Aufrufe hatten, alle machen sich nur drüber lustig, keine Ahnung, ich weiß
auch nicht, wie das dahin gekommen ist, ich kenne den Kell eigentlich nur von früher ab
und zu, wo er beim Nico rumgesprungen ist und ich hab mich damals schon immer gefragt,
was zum, ja, okay, also es haben verdammt viele Fachinformatiker gelernt, guck mal, wenn
60% nein gestimmt haben und 40% ja, das ist saumäßig viel, ja, so, ich muss jetzt mal
kurz gucken, dass ich die aufhole, im Chat, also wichtig ist, du musst, du musst halt
was können, ja, da kannst du schön den ganzen, ja, beim, beim, beim Fenster, beim, als Computerfuzzi
beim Fensterbauer, ja, da kannst du wahrscheinlich das, äh, in der Richtung machen, ja, wobei
die schreiben ja auch, die schreiben ja auch, äh, du machst Konfiguration der Firmendomäne,
das ist schon mal abfuck, hätte ich gar keinen Bock drauf, also, hast du Fachinformatiker
gelernt, bezieht sich da auf die IRK-Ausbildung oder ob man das, was, ja, Fachinformatiker
bei der IRK, ging da, ging da drum, wie viele das hier gelernt haben, ähm, also das ist
schon mal abfuck, da hätte ich als Niedungsmann absolut keinen Bock drauf, ähm, dann machst
du irgendwelche Firewall-Geschichten und VPN-Anbindungen, ok, die suchen im Endeffekt wirklich den
Mann für alles, oder die Frau für alles, oder die, die AdministratorInnen suchen, die
AdministratorInnen, Konfiguration der Installation der Hardware aller mobilen Endgeräte und
das, das ist verdammt viel, was die wollen, das ist ne One-Man-Show, das ist wirklich,
äh, ja, Depp für alles, im Endeffekt, äh, Beschaffung neuer Hard- und Software zu allen
oben genannten Themen, Mitarbeiter in der Entwicklung eigen, WTF, sollst du auch noch
die Website und den Shop entwickeln, ok, das ist halt echt, das ist halt echt der Witz,
das ist halt wirklich wieder so ein Ding, wir suchen einen Mann für alles, hey, das, genau,
Full-Stack, Alter, Full-Stack, das Problem ist, ähm, was sagst du dazu, äh, Moment,
muss ich mal kopieren, ich muss mal gucken, dass ich ein bisschen hinten, ich bin ein
bisschen hinterher mit dem Chat, der Link geht nicht, ein Giant Master, muss ich gleich
nochmal, ähm, genau, das wollte ich, das wollte ich dir noch dazu sagen, das ist gar
nicht so weit hergeholt, ja, also ja, es ist der Depp für alles, aber das ist gerade
früher und in kleineren Firmen ist das noch an der Tagesordnung, man muss aber sagen,
dass es schon, also wenn man das alles auch noch halbwegs gut können soll, ist das eigentlich
utopisch, ja, du mein, du suchst ja, du kannst, du, du musst, wisst ihr, wie man unterm Strich
sagen muss, ich glaube, du musst so der klassische, der klassische Turnschuh-Frickel-Admin sein,
um sowas machen zu können, das ist jetzt gar nicht mal großartig negativ gemeint, ich
mach das auch gerne, ihr wisst, wie gerne ich an Sachen rumbastele und stundenlang an
irgendwas rumfrickele, bis es funktioniert, ähm, genau, du musst, du musst halt so dieser,
so der klassische, ich nenne, wie nenne ich es mal, 90er Jahre-Admin sein, also permanent,
permanent unterwegs, permanent am Rumdebacken rumfrickeln, gucken, wie es irgendwie hingeht,
äh, wirklich, wirklich, sag mal mal, gute, technisch ausgereifte Lösung mit Tiefgang
eher nicht, Hauptsache schnell, dass es wieder geht, ja, ich mein, es kommt halt, als erstes
kommt mal Windows-AD dazu, Windows-AD hast du Millionen Leute, die sowas machen, aber
wirklich richtig Schlaue gibt es da relativ wenig, das merke ich bei uns auf der Arbeit,
wir haben ein ganzes Team, was sich um Active Directory, Domains und Windows und, und, äh,
Zeug kümmert, mir fällt allerdings genau einer ein und eine, ja, wir haben in Windows tatsächlich,
im Windows-Team tatsächlich, Administratorinnen und, also, Administratorinnen und Administratorinnen,
und wir haben eine, die hat auch echt Plan, und wir haben noch einen anderen, der hat auch
echt Plan, aber den Rest, kannst du ehrlich gesagt, naja, ich will nicht sagen, dass sie
gar keinen Plan haben, aber, so für die komplizierten Sachen würde ich einen von den beiden anrufen,
ja, also das ist, das ist schon unglaublich, äh, umfangreiches Thema, ähm, Firewall
und VPN-Anbindung ist auch ein äußerst umfangreiches Thema, ähm, vor allem ist das ein, ist das
ein Thema, wo man viel verkacken kann, also, stell euch mal vor, für Peter Agile, ne, der
macht doch sowas nicht, denen fehlt schon mal das Dainyscrum und das Kanban Board, dass
sie das machen, ich zeige jetzt auch nicht nochmal, wer es ist, mir geht, ach, da steht
es ja sogar, äh, mir geht es nur so, wie ich das interpretieren würde, diese Stellenanzeige,
das muss nicht schlecht sein, der Laden, ne, by the way, das muss echt nicht schlecht sein,
aber ich glaube, da sind halt spezielle Skills gefragt, dass man da gut reinpasst, ja, ähm,
und hier kannst du halt auch sehr viel versauen, wenn du keine Ahnung hast, überlegt euch
mal, du bist jemand, der, quasi, so ein Frickler, der alles macht, wie gesagt, sowas wird ja
da eindeutig gebraucht, bei Roffel Fensterbau und, das war so Pains Jam, das war so schlecht
der Witz, Alter, ähm, du bist jemand, der halt gerne rumbastelt und das, wisst ihr,
was man dann macht als jemand, man guckt sich ein YouTube Video an, how to OpenVPN und baut
das danach auf, das Problem ist halt nur, dass, gerade, wenn es um VPN-Anbindung in
die Firma geht, das sollte schon jemand machen, der ein bisschen Plan von der Sache hat, weil
oftmals haben die dann auch nur ein Netz oder sonst was, sprich, du bist drinnen und hast
Zugriff auf alles, da kann auch mal ganz schnell so einer wie der Twinko herkommen und Datenbank
dampft ziehen, wenn man da nicht aufpasst, ja, Konfiguration, Installation der Hardware,
aller mobilen Endgeräte und der TK-Anlage, das ist auch echt ein extrem brutal weit gefasster
Bereich, ne, 100 Mitarbeiter, das ist ganz schön viel, ich hätte jetzt eher gedacht,
das ist so ein Ding mit maximal 10 Leuten, das ist auch ein ultra weit gefasster Bereich,
ich meine, Konfiguration, Installation der Hardware, klar, wenn es um Windows Desktop
geht oder so, kein Problem, aber alle mobilen Endgeräte bedeutet auch Mobile Device Management
und gedönnt, je nachdem, was die haben und der Telefonanlage und ich kann euch aus eigener
oder nicht wirklich langer Erfahrung sagen, probier es nochmal, ne, der Link funktioniert
nicht, Giant Master, ich geb dir nen Tipp, mach nen Shortlink draus und schick den nochmal,
da sind Sonderzeichen drin, das funktioniert sonst nicht, ich kann aus nur sehr kurzer
eigene Erfahrung sagen, VoIP und Telefon ist abfuck extrem, weiß nicht, macht es einer
von euch, Chet? Macht einer Telefon, irgendwie? Okay, gib, gib, gib ein paar, also, ne, ich
will es jetzt nicht schlecht machen, du brauchst auch Leute, die das können, aber für mich,
ich find's halt extrem undurchsichtig, was VoIP und Telefonsachen angeht, das ist so
schwarze Magie für mich, du hast vor ein paar Wochen mal telefoniert, nur mit Bill Gates,
ansonsten lass ich das nicht durchgehen, das ist halt ein wirklich total komplexes Gebiet
mit teilweise Sachen, die 60 Jahre alt sind, ja, ich hab da nochmal ganz kurz was mit zu
tun gehabt bzw. war dabei und hab mir gedacht, was, was geht hier, also TK Anlage ist auch
schon mal Hardcore, ja, Beschaffung neuer Hard- und Software zu allen umgenannten Themen,
d.h. du machst auch noch den Einkauf oder sowas, also immer, so, dann machst du, dann entwickelst
du mit an ERP, was war denn das nochmal, Customer Real Estate, was ist ERP? Resource Planning,
ich kann mir diese ganzen, Enterprise Resource Planning, oh das bestimmt SAP oder sowas,
Paynes Champ, habt ihr gehört, ich hab irgendwo gelesen, dass Google jetzt SAP Software eingekauft
hat, so, und am Shop-System wahrscheinlich PHP, im Zweifelsfall ist es PHP, wollen wir
wetten, dass es PHP, Leute, das Shop-System ist unter Garantie PHP, Gucken wir mal, wir
gucken mal kurz, wir gucken mal kurz, Rollfensterbau, Roffelfensterbau, oh, ja ja, Shop, also eins
muss man sagen, die Homepage ist durchaus ok, also da kann man es nicht sagen, wahrscheinlich
WordPress Vorlage oder sowas, keine Ahnung, wo ist denn der Shop, Shop, wo ist der Shop,
jetzt sollte es gehen, jetzt funktioniert's, ja, jetzt funktioniert's, ja, kann ich mir
klar angucken, seht ihr da irgendwie den Shop, ach, Business to Business Shop, ja, das kann
sein, ah gut, wollen wir den Shop jetzt angucken, Händler, Händlershop, das hier ist der Shop,
der Haustür-Konfigurator, ah, exzellent, exzellent, anmelden, also das ist auch schon,
ich wette mit euch, komm, kriegen wir irgendwie raus, ob das PHP ist, eigentlich nicht so
wirklich, aber manches sieht vielleicht PHP aus, soll ich mal, ja, schau mal, mach sie
nicht kaputt, steht da, hat da irgendwie einer PHP drinne vergessen, PHP Session ID, ok,
es ist irgendwie PHP, alles klar, manchmal reicht schon, wenn man einfach nach PHP sucht,
schau mal kurz, Inspect, Cookies, fuck, wo war das mal, Cookies, Network, Application,
Cookies, Magento, ah, das ist ein Magento-System, das ist ein Shopping, ein Shop-System, da
muss man überhaupt nicht wirklich dran rumprobieren, PHP Session ID, alles klar, ok, es ist ein
Magento, also ein PHP Ding, ok, passt, exzellent, Magento hab ich früher auch mal was gemacht,
sehr, sehr viel früher, als das rausgekommen ist und sich alle gefreut haben, dass es
endlich mal eine gescheite neue Shop-Software gibt, ganz, ganz lang her, bestimmt, boah,
18 Jahre oder so, ewig her, ewig her, wann ist das rausgekommen, ok, 20 Jahre net, 13
Jahre, ok, ich hab nix gesagt, aber es kam auf jeden Fall lang, lang vor, nein, geht
nicht los, ganzen Tag nicht, so, genau, da hätten wir das und der Linux ist Teams echt
suboptimal, ich kann's ehrlich gesagt gar nicht genau beurteilen, ich verwende das nicht
unter Linux, hey Max, ich hab mal geschaut, wie ich mich am längsten auf YouTube folge,
das bist du seit 2000 äußerst nice, dazu kann ich bloß sagen, und natürlich, und
natürlich, exzellent, jetzt kannst du ja noch im Stream gucken, das sind, ist wichtig
zur IQ steigernden Maßnahmen, sollte eigentlich zur Daily-Routine gehören, weil ich hab bestimmt
jede Menge Subs übersehen, easykiller, 18 Monate, hab ich gar nicht gesehen, so was
bin ich noch nicht im Chat, dankeschön für den Sub, huge Hyper-Subscription, no limitxo,
11 Monate, das ist ja eins vor Hyper-Subscriber, FlixGP, 6 Monate, huge Subscription, Adrian
Poolstream, sehr guter Name, danke für den Prime-Sub, du und Semper-Video sind dran
schuld, dass ich Fachinformatiker bin, ja gut, ist was Schlimmes, machst du Homeoffice
vom privaten Rechner und Desktop, ja, also bei uns funktioniert das folgendermaßen,
du hast zwei Varianten, entweder du nimmst, du hast ein offizielles Windows Notebook von
der Firma, das nimmst du mit heim, nachdem ich ja äußerst ungern Windows verwende zum
Arbeiten, wisst ihr ja, fällt das bei mir schonmal flach, das heißt, ich verwende Remote,
das ganze, wenn ich was brauche, ansonsten mach ich das hier so weit wie es geht in meiner
Siedlungs-VM, wenn man eben was basteln muss oder so geht das ja da auch, magst du, was
war eigentlich dein Fazit zu Flutter, oh ich kann da noch gar kein Fazit ziehen, ich bin
ja, ich bin ja nur wirklich, äh, gestern hab ich es erstmal mit in Berührung gekommen,
was Flutter angeht, ich fand's gar nicht schlecht, was ich bis jetzt gesehen hab, nach was soll
ich denn suchen, wenn ich nach der Ausbildung eine Stelle suche, ähm, naja, es kommt ein
bisschen drauf an, in welchem Bereich du was haben willst, ja, also, kann man jetzt echt
schwer sagen, schau dir mal in die Stellenbeschreibung an, ok, zeig mal her, welche denn die da,
ne, Moment, ne, das ist Roffelfensterbau, hab ich die eben schon aufgemacht, Moment,
hab ich die eben schon geöffnet, ach ne, hier die hab ich aufm, auf der Vorschau schon
aufgemacht, also, Mitarbeiter MWD, ich finde, ich finde das echt im Jahr 2021 ganz schön
frech, dass die nur männlich weiß Deutsche suchen, also, das sollte schon ein bisschen
diverser sein, finde ich, in Vollzeit, IT Support, ok, IT Support ist was, da hätt'
ich jetzt persönlich keinen, ich geb' zu, immer der gleiche Witz und immer der Pains
Champion Witz, ja, ist gut, ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß, dafür kriegt ihr Pool, Wasserpool
Spritzer heute unten links, so, also, das wär' jetzt nicht unbedingt was, wo ich scharf
drauf gewesen, also, scharf drauf wäre, aber jedem, jedem das, worer Lust drauf hat, ne,
so, also, bei wem denn, beim Bayerischen Landesamt für Gesundheit und Lebensmittelsicherheit,
IT Support, dafür braucht man noch keine echte Ausbildung, sagt der Chat, na ja, also,
kommt drauf an, ob man unfähiger, unhilf-, also, unfähiger und nicht hilfreiche IT Support
sein will oder auch einer, der was kann, dann ist ne Ausbildung sicherlich nicht verkehrt,
ok, gesund leben können, dazu gehören gesunde, ok, bla, bla, bla, die übliche Lobreisung
auf den eigenen Laden, setzt doch mal bitte noch die Katze auf den Poolrand, hab' ich
ein Bild von der Katze, ah, nochmal, hab' ich ein Bild, hab' ich ein Bild von der Katze,
ich hab' doch hier Chico irgendwo, wo ist Chico, Chico, Chico, Chico, kriegen wir das
irgendwie gebacken, die passt da, glaub' ich, nicht wirklich gut hin auf den Poolrand,
feini, ja, nee, die Katze, ich kann die Katze auf den, auf den Vorleger legen, da unten,
Bild freistellen, ich mein', was mach' ich jetzt gerade noch, Bildbearbeitung hier,
mach' ich jetzt die Bildbearbeitung in dem Schrieb, wissen Sie, wie viel, das haben
wir schon mal gemacht, das war Chebathe, kann man Badewasser irgendwo kaufen, oh, das
ist ne gute Idee, Moment, Moment, das muss in die Subgoals, wir müssen den Subgoal dafür
wegmachen, hallo, warum geht das nicht, ähm, Oberteil wechseln machen wir weg, ich würd'
sagen 25 Subs, 25 Subs, Bade, Badewasser, so, so ist das perfekt, so lassen wir das jetzt,
okay, jetzt gucken wir erst mal das vom, vom Giant Master fertig an, also, das Bayerische
Landesamt für Gesundheit, Lebensmittelsicherheit sucht für das Sachgebiet Z4, das ist natürlich
besonders geil, in Stellenanzeigen, äh, irgendwelche, bürokratischen Dinger reinzuhauen, das Sachgebiet
Z4, das Sachgebiet Z4 ist anscheinend Informationstechnik und EDF, oh, Painschamp-Begriff, EDF,
EDF, ah, jetzt C4, äh, ne, äh, nicht C4, Z4, C4 ist, äh, Monka, Monka Explosion, hast
du Schulden, hat Belldelfin Schulden, braucht, braucht man Schulden für Subgoals, so, ähm,
das Bayerische Landesamt für Gesundheit, so, äh, Mitarbeiter, MWD, IT-Support, vielseitige
Aufgaben, die sich herausfordern, Installation, Auslieferung von IT-Arbeitsplätzen, Telefon,
Drucker, äh, Giant Master, was hast du gelernt, Fachinformatik, Systemintegration, bist du
schon fertig oder wirst du dieses Jahr fertig, wenn man mal so fragen darf.
Okay, okay, weil, Chat, weil ihr seid, oh, ne, Smokatoss, äh, wie kann man hier was
hochladen, U-Post, Job-Image, weil ihr seid, wir machen jetzt, ich, ich lass jetzt den
Chainlaw, oder, äh, genau, lass ich jetzt den, das freistellen und dann kann er sich
freuen, das machen wir dann an den Pool, ja, Matt, ja, es ist eindeutig für Erwachsene,
wobei, das lass ich lieber weg, Hidden, Copy Link, hier, Chainlaw, hau rein, Katzenstelz
am Start, lerne im Juli aus, Fizi, okay, ähm, ganz ehrlich, ich würde an deiner Stelle
versuchen, was anderes zu kriegen, das hier, also, ich kann ja immer nur aus meiner Sicht
sprechen, ne, übrigens hier riecht Flashbang gerade, ich muss mal, es ist wieder dunkel,
Mann, ich kann jetzt nur aus meiner Sicht sprechen, ich bin jemand, der hat äußerst
ungern täglich mit Leuten zu tun und noch unlieber, also, noch weniger gerne mit Leuten,
die, äh, keine Ahnung haben und einem auf den Sack gehen, also, im Prinzip, der Inbegriff
von Leuten, mit denen man jeden Tag im Support zu tun hat, also, äh, also, für mich wäre,
für mich wäre es jetzt nicht, für mich wäre es nichts, das heißt, ich würde mir jetzt
eher erst mal überlegen, ähm, wenn du eine Ausbildung gemacht hast und du scheinst ja
auch es so zu sehen, dass du es wohl gut schaffst im Juli, wenn du da fertig wirst und ich vermute
auch mal, dass dein aktueller Betrieb dich nicht übernimmt, weil sonst, sonst würdest
du den nicht suchen, ich würde mal gucken, dass ich irgendwas finde in dem Gebiet, was
mich interessiert, was sind denn so, sag doch mal ein Gebiet, was dich interessiert, also,
was du gerne machst und wo du dich auch gut auskennst, dann kann ich dir vielleicht irgendwas
sagen, was in diese Richtung geht, ja, aber, pff, also, ganz ehrlich, Support wäre für
mich nichts, wenn du dich gerne täglich mit Leuten rum ärgerst, ok, aber, also, ja,
für mich wäre es nichts, ja, Erfahrung im öffentlichen Dienst ist wünschenswert, wenn
man da Erfahrung gemacht hat, ist man da wahrscheinlich möglichst schnell weg, ähm, gute Kenntnis
im Bereich Standard Hardware Software, Windows 10, Enterprise, äh, aktuelle Microsoft Office
Produkte, ah ja, alles klar, ist der Fachinformat der gleiche wie IT-Technik oder Systemtechnik
in Österreich, ich hab keine Ahnung, ok, das ist Standard, Standard, blablabla, hier,
Monkastier, ja, Nutzungsmöglichkeit einer E-Ladesäule, wisst ihr was, es schreiben
viel zu wenige wirklich sinnvolle Sachen hin, und das ist sinnvoll, ich seh das total oft,
dass die Leute, äh, in Stellen anzeigen, dass die im Prinzip bei Vorteile schreiben
die dann so Sachen rein wie, ähm, der größte Anbieter in diesem Bereich, wo ich mir immer
denke, ja, und wo genau ist jetzt der Vorteil für mich, oder, oder, äh, was stand bei
der Bahn, ein internationales Team, das ist für mich jetzt auch nicht so wirklich von,
von Relevanz, ja, das sind Punkte, die find ich tatsächlich relativ wichtig, ich mein,
Kantine vor Ort ist geil, kostenfreie Parkmöglichkeiten ist geil, E-Ladesäule ist geil, äh, gut,
der Rest ist halt eher so, so Standardgedöns.
Am liebsten im Gebiet Virtualisierung vor MWR und möchte mal später im Gebiet Security
arbeiten, ja, dann, auf geht's, vor MWR, vor MWR in die Suchmaschine eingeben, vor MWR
werden einige Leute gesucht.
Äh, vorausgesetzt natürlich, dass du dich ein bisschen auskennst, ansonsten ist es ja
allgemein schwierig, wenn man keine Ahnung von irgendwas hat, gib in die Suche vor MWR
ein und such, gib's genug?
Vor MWR ist sogar, oder generell Virtualisierung ist, äh, ein Thema, da werden Leute gesucht.
Was, die Katze ist, die Katze ist freigestellt, ok Leute, exzellent, exzellent, die Katze
ist freigestellt.
Wo ist der Weihnachts-Cack-Wade hin, wir haben ne Umfrage gemacht und der Weihnachts-Cack-Wade
sollte, ist jetzt freigestellt oder nicht?
Flo69, 17 Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub, das ist ja schon Massive Hypersubscription,
ich mach jetzt auch extra mal den Pool-Sound an, dass das hier alles ein bisschen Gamer-Badewasser
mäßig wirkt.
Dankeschön für den Sub, das ist ja richtig, die eine Version ist besser, Chainlaw, äh,
das stimmt, die Version von Chainlaw ist tatsächlich besser, guck mal, die Version von Chainlaw
ist tatsächlich besser, äh, freie Katze, so, also soll ich das jetzt da reinbauen, ok,
die soll sich auf den Rand setzen, habt ihr gesagt, add image, freie Katze, die kann sich
ja auch da unten hinlegen, oder, kann die sich, kann die sich nicht auch einfach so
da vorlegen, hier ist doch auch gut, oder, ich muss mal ne Vorschau gucken, ja, das ist
auch gut, da kann die sich da vorlegen, das ist gut so, Feinie, Feinie, Feinie Katze,
wobei ich, ich red mit meiner Katze nicht so, ich, ich, äh, red aber auch dummes Zeug
mit der Katze, ich sag nicht Feinie, Feinie, ähm, die heißt, das ist ja eine Sie und heißt
Chico, hat sich der Vorbesitzer irgendwas bei gedacht, wenn die kommt, dann sag ich
was, Chico, Chico, komm mal her, Chico, Chico, Chico, und dann kommt sie an und denkt sich,
leckt mich am Arsch und geht wieder weg, so typisch Katzenstellzeit, hinter den Keks
wegen der Ecke, nee, hinter den Keks sieht nicht gut aus, da steht ja eine Katze C Sharp,
also, es gibt ja, es gibt ja so Leute, die haben Affen drauf trainiert, Memory zu spielen,
ich hab so nicht probiert meine Katze auf C Sharp zu trainieren, vielleicht wird es die
erste Programmer Kat, Ecker Kat, die spricht nur Assembly, ja, das stimmt, so, ähm, ja,
Problem ist, dass ich nicht besonders viel in der Ausbildung gelernt habe und hauptsächlich
im Ticket Support Office bin, ja gut, dann hast du jetzt ja noch ein paar Monate Zeit,
dich mit dem Thema zu beschäftigen, ein bisschen was können, das dich halt als Vmware einstellt,
musst du schon, ja, musst dich halt privat mit, also nach Möglichkeit ein bisschen auf
der Arbeit, wenn es noch irgendwie möglich ist, oder musst dich halt privat damit beschäftigen,
aber ganz im Ernst, die meisten Sachen, zumindest meiner Erfahrung nach, die meisten Sachen,
die man so lernt, lernt man eh hauptsächlich privat und nicht primär in der Firma, also,
die meisten Sachen lernt man dadurch, dass man das jeweilige Thema interessiert und man
sich einfach intensiv mit auseinandersetzt, nicht so sehr, weil man irgendwie eine Schulung
auf der Arbeit kriegt oder da einem was vorgekaut wird, also im Prinzip, ich hab die meisten
Sachen auch gelernt, weil es mich interessiert, ja, angefangen mit der ganzen Linux-Geschichte,
sonst hätte ich ja den ganzen Job nie gemacht, den ich jetzt mache, ähm, weiter mit meinem
Microcontroller Zeug, bisschen Elektronik Kram, Programmier Kram, alles das, was mich
interessiert hat, und wenn Vmware ein Thema ist, was dich interessiert, dann fällt es
dir auch, denke ich, immer gar nicht schwer, da halt ein bisschen Zeit rein zu versenken
und dich mit auseinanderzusetzen.
Du kannst mittlerweile Vmware übrigens auf Raspberry Pi machen, das stimmt, gibt's jetzt,
allerdings bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob das die beste Idee ist, weiß nicht, wie gut
das auf Raspberry Pi läuft, allerdings denke ich mal, dass so reine Virtualisierung durchaus
aussterben wird, also ich würde mal, wir hatten doch, warte mal, wo hab ich denn dieses Dokument
hin?
Das war das, was ich nicht so gut fand, ja, aber wir haben ja ein eigenes gemacht, aber
es ist definitiv auch nicht verkehrt, sich neben der Virtualisierung noch mit ein bisschen
Basics, was aktuelle Cloud-Technologie angeht, auseinanderzusetzen, also gerade in der Form
von, äh, wo ist es denn hier, genau, einmal ganze Container-Geschichte.
Provisioning und, ähm, wo steht die überhaupt, Virtualisierung, steht hier irgendwo Virtualisierung
drin?
Seht ihr irgendwo Virtualisierung?
Ich seh es nicht.
Na gut, ist auch egal.
Ähm, aber gerade, gerade, bisschen Cloud-Technologien würde ich mir auf jeden Fall angucken, weil
es gibt immer weniger, die diesen ganzen Kram bei sich lokal laufen lassen, ok, oder on-prem,
wie die coolen krassen Cloud-Native-Leute heutzutage sagen.
So, jetzt muss ich mal Chat hier gucken, ich komm ja überhaupt nicht wieder her.
Ähm, was hatten wir jetzt?
Hab ich schon vorgelesen aus dem Dankeschön für den Sub?
Ja, das ist, das ist halt der Witz, ne?
Die suchen im Prinzip niemand, der alles wirklich gut kann, die suchen jemand, der alles irgendwie
hinfrickeln kann.
Das ist das, was man so 90er-, 2000er-Jahre, äh, unter so den klassischen Turnschuh-Admin-Leuten
halt verbreitet war.
Ich mach das ja auch unglaublich gern, einfach an Sachen rumfrickeln, bis sie irgendwie gehen,
wirklich tiefgreifend durchdachte Lösungen kommen da halt nicht raus, ja.
Die Frage ist nur, was der Unterschied zwischen der Ausbildung ist, ehrlich gesagt, bei den
neuen IHK-Ausbildungen, keine Ahnung.
So, ja, ist so, ist so, ja, bin ich ja froh, dass du gerade als IHK-Prüfer so siehst.
Ein agiler Software, was macht ein agiler Software-Tester?
Ist ja, macht er täglich, äh, Stand-Up, der testet nur im Stehen, oder?
Letztendlich braucht man keinen agilen Software-Tester, man braucht Leute, die in, nennen wir es mal,
agilen Umgebung zurechtkommen.
Übrigens, heute auf der Arbeit, ich muss so lachen, ich, ich muss so lachen, die wollen,
ich muss jetzt versuchen, ein bisschen, bisschen zu umschreiben, die wollen den USB-Test machen
und Strom abschalten.
Und da hab ich als Einwand gebracht, es arbeiten sehr viele Leute gerade remote, wenn ihr nicht
schnell genug den Strom wieder eingeschaltet habt, dann sind die Akkus von den Notebooks
leer und niemand ist da, um die Notebooks wieder einzuschalten, ob das so eine gute Idee ist.
Und die Antwort darauf war, ist jetzt kein Witz, ähm, wenn die, wenn die, also die Antwort
darauf war, wenn die Wartungsarbeiten länger dauern, da werden wir einen, jetzt haltet
euch fest, Poggersward, dann werden wir einen Floor-Walker einsetzen, der die Notebooks
wieder startet.
Was ist denn ein Floor-Walker, ist das so, sowas wie der Day-Walker, weiß ich, ob jemand
Blade gesehen hat früher, das sind irgendwelche Vampire oder was, ich sag ja, wie, das hat
was von Day, von Day-Walker, nein, nein, nein, nein, der will mich nicht verarschen,
das hat er in der Besprechung gesagt, mit 40 Leuten drin, der wollte uns nicht chibaten,
das genau sehe ich nicht, der Day-Walker ist der Floor-Walker, solche Termonologie verwendet
man gerne auch im IT-Support, oh, wieder was, was nicht für IT-Support spricht, Tronax
YouTube, 6 Monate, exquisite Subscription, Massive, Marzi, Dankeschön für den Sub,
vor 7 Minuten habe ich nicht gesehen, trotzdem, huge IQ-Increase wieder, Flo96 auch am Start,
17 Monate, obbei, das habe ich glaube ich schon vorgelesen, oder, habe ich schon, Massive,
Easy Killer auch wieder, 18 Monate, huge, ein Agile Jumper Floor-Walker, das braucht
man genau, so, schnell, schnell weiter scrollen hier, das muss man nicht wissen, das ist
nicht so wichtig 2021 mehr zu wissen, ja, das vermute ich auch mal, dass du da nicht
reich wirst von, ja, gehe ich auch mal von aus, hey, dein Hahn muss nicht schlecht sein,
wie gesagt, es ist halt, es ist halt eher so, wie ich mir das 2000 drum in der Admin-Stelle
vorgestellt habe, und ein 100, ein Betrieb mit 100 Leuten sollte sich schon eine IT leisten
können, die nicht aus einem Mann besteht, der alles können muss, bei 100 Leuten, das
ist jetzt auch nicht gerade klein, ja, also, wenn man jemanden haben will, der wirklich
Plan hat von Telefon, dann auf jeden Fall, so, wir gehen jetzt hier beim Schnelldurchlauf
durch, SAP Stream, also es gibt ein paar Sachen, die werde ich nicht streamen, SAP gehört
dazu, Leute, hat jemand von euch, Frage, hat jemand von euch ein JetBrains Abo, All Desktop
oder All, All Products, nicht All Products, All Desktop, All Desktop, All Desktop, Moment,
Moment, Moment, äh, wo ist das denn, nicht das All Products, das meine ich nicht, das
All Desktop, tja, ich finde, das jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht, ja, ich würde, ich würde einfach
mal interessieren, so im Nachhinein, hat es sich gelohnt für euch, weil ich, ich bin,
ich bin kurz davor, mir ein Jahresabo zu kaufen, zumal da kam auch gar nicht mal so teuer
ist, All Products Pack, genau, genau, genau, das da, ich meine, wenn man, man verdient
ja damit, naja gut, je nachdem, was man damit macht, verdient man nicht zwangsläufig Geld,
aber es ist ja eigentlich eine ganz gute Investition, ist das nicht alles free, du hast eine Trial-Variante,
die ist free und du kannst die Trial mit ein bisschen Tricks, äh, ja, resetten, aber will
ich natürlich keines dazu anstiften, ja, weil, was ich auch cool finde, ist, dass das, wenn
du dabei bleibst, dass du ab dem dritten Jahr nur 150 Euro bezahlst und 150 Euro ist durchaus
in Ordnung für das, was die bieten, ich meine, du hast, guck mal, ich muss mal nur danach
gehen, was ich davon benutzen würde, ja, also ich würde C-Line verwenden, ab und zu mal,
ich würde, ähm, ich würde Go-Land verwenden, ab und zu mal öfter, ich würde Rider sehr
oft verwenden, fast täglich, ich würde mir auf jeden Fall nochmal Webstorm angucken,
weil mir Visual Studio Code teilweise auf den Keks geht, ähm, also das ist allein schon
billiger, als den ganzen Kram allein zu kaufen, App-Code hab ich keine Ahnung, woher ich das
kann, App-Code hab ich keine Ahnung, was das ist, Datacrypt weiß ich auch nicht,.trace
ist glaube ich, den, den, ähm, die Compiler, ne, den.net-Decompiler ist das glaube ich,
Datacrypt ist Datenbank, gut, das hätte ich mir jetzt denken können, aber Datenbank,
null, SQLite for life, wer braucht schon Datenbank, Alter, Datenbank, overrated, outdated,
gebated, heute machen wir einfach überall Cloud-Native-Database, was auch immer das
heißen soll, ich sag das jetzt einfach mal so und dann haben wir keine Probleme mit Datenbanken,
Ruby-Mine, achso, sorry, nicht Ruby-Mine, Ruby-Mine, neue Katze, warum, oh, die ist
gut hier, die, die Cat-Freigestellte ist gut, Freigestellte Chico, allerdings die passt
da, ich find die liegende Chico schon besser, ok, also ihr meint das lohnt sich, ja, ok,
Cloud-Native-Serverless-Database, ja, klar, ich find, ich find vor allem Serverless, Serverless,
also, also, ich mein Serverless ist der, ist im Prinzip die größte Gebate-Bezeichnung
aller Zeiten, das hört sich so an, als wären da gerade keine Server mehr beteiligt, das
ist ja genauer der Gegenteil, das genaue Gegenteil ist der Fall, die Sachen werden nach wie
vor am Ende, wenn es eine Web-Anwendung ist, von irgendeine Web-Server ausgeliefert, ich
mein, du brauchst nicht mehr zwangsläufig bei dir was stehen haben, ich mein, was kommt
dann als nächstes, Infrastructure-S-Code-Serverless, mit Cloud-Native-Orchestrierung-Server, was
auch immer, also, ja, Gebate, demnächst denkst du einfach nur was und die App ist fertig,
so, Google, genau das hab ich vorhin auch gelesen, das heißt, demnächst stimmen die
Abrechnung auf Twitch, äh, auf YouTube nicht mehr, oder wie ist das, aber ich find das
schon geil, dass Google das nicht selber macht, normalerweise macht der Google sau viel selber,
so, mal bisschen schneller hier drüber, ja, kann man, muss ja nicht schlecht sein, ne,
wie kommt man denn aus IT-Support raus, das beste ist glaube ich erst gar nicht reinkommen,
in IT-Support, ne, die Katze bleibt da vorliegen, was das, ja, das kenn ich, die haben mich
bei Xing angeschrieben, was denkste, Regio IT klingt, Regio hat was mit der Bahn zu tun,
wir suchen für unser Operation Center, ok, Operation Center klingt nach 24-7-Support,
gucken wir mal, ob da was von Schichtarbeit drin steht, ähm, nutzen sie den Freiraum,
wir bieten ihnen flexible Arbeitzeiten ohne Kernearbeitzeiten, ja, das klingt nach Schichtarbeit,
das klingt nach Schichtarbeit, ähm, entwickeln sie sich weiter persönliche, ok, bla bla bla,
seien sie willkommen, ähm, ja, planen sie mit uns unsere Zukunft, das ist tatsächlich
ein guter Vorteil, das finde ich cool, sowas, wenn die das haben, das soll, das soll alle
dabei schreiben, weil für Leute mit Kindern ist das glaube ich echt ein riesiger Pluspunkt,
dass sie sich nicht um Kindergarten, Kindergartenplätze kümmern müssen, nicht nochmal extra, äh,
rumfahren müssen, sondern einfach die Kinder mit auf die Arbeit nehmen können, Kinder
gehen ins Kindergarten und auf dem Heimweg kommen sie wieder mit, wenn man jetzt noch,
genau, jetzt noch das Betriebs-Altersheim dabei, da kann man Opa, Oma noch oder Vater,
je nachdem wie alt man ist, aber das finde ich gut, das sollten alle reinschreiben, vielfältiges
Gesundheitsangebot, Massagen, nein, die meinen sicherlich was anderes, äh, Bio-Äpfel-Wasser-Gesundheitstage
zurückgreifen, ja, Bio-Äpfel, ja, warum nicht, das ist doch nice, das ist doch nice,
ich finde, finde ich das nicht schlecht, Chainlaw ist das deine, Paynes Champ, niedliche Katz,
ja gut, wenn man keine Kinder hat, da ist natürlich kein Vorteil, mir geht es nur darum,
die Unternehmen sollten mehr so Sachen hinschreiben, meine, nein Chainlaw, das ist nicht
meine Katze, weiß nicht, wo du das her hast, das ist nicht meine, was eh mal die Kollege
arbeitet jetzt für eine Krankenkasse und die stellen kein Wasser und Obst bereit, haben
sie keine Angst, Leute denken sie verschwenden Kastengelder eher, was soll das heißen mit
den 50 Subs Game Attack auf Oberschenkel, du kennst dich im aktuellen Twitch Pool Streaming
Meta eindeutig nicht aus, das muss man heutzutage eigentlich wissen, das ist nur ein Witz oben,
also ich meine das nicht ernst, wie findest du das, okay, Chainmaster ein gucke ich mir
noch an von dir, also zeig mal her, aber du musst doch selbst, eigentlich ist es doch
vollkommen egal, wie ich das finde, es muss dich doch ansprechen, also IT System und Netzwerk
Amistral, okay, das ist jetzt mal was ganz anderes zu VMWare, Anwender Support, okay,
da hört es bei mir schon auf, malst du dir meinen Namen auf den Arm, wenn ich Subbe,
ne, wenn du Subs nicht, einfacher Sub reicht nicht, ich freue mich, wenn du Subs, aber
einfacher Sub reicht nicht, für einen Sub kriegst du, kriegst du Link zu meinem OnlyFans
Account, und da kannst du den Rest reinputtern, also, Anwender Support würde mich ja schon
mal abschrecken, okay, nein, das ist Müll, das ist nichts, ich meine ernsthaft, was ist
denn mit denen los, guck mal, die schreiben, die schreiben, du machst Anwender Support,
vor Ort Fernwartung per Telefon, also du bist im Prinzip mehr oder weniger den ganzen Tag
mit Support beschäftigt, so bei Software und Hardware-Technik, so, und dann, und dann machst
du zusätzlich noch Installation, Configuration, Administration von Server und kleinen Systeme
mit Windows Betriebssystem, dann machst du zusätzlich noch Installation, Configuration,
Administration von Netzwerk-Komponenten, dann machst du zusätzlich noch Installation, Configuration,
Administration von IT-Sicherheitslösen in Firewalls, zusätzlich machst du noch Installation,
Configuration, Administration von Exchange, und dazu machst du dann auch noch Installation,
Configuration, Administration, Virtualisierungslösung, vor allem bei Hyper-V, und damit das Ganze
noch nicht reicht, das wird dann noch abgerundet, das ist ja noch nicht genug, kann man ja mal
erwarten, dass das jemand kann, um das noch ganz noch abzurunden, Installation und Configuration
von Datensicherungssystem, kommt auch noch mal so was wie TSM oder so wahrscheinlich
ist das, oder was immer die für Datensicherungen haben, Unterstützung bei Administration von
kundenseitigen Spezialanwendungen, da musst du ja noch Ahnung von haben, Infrastruktur-Dokumentation,
das ist doch ein Witz oder, das ist doch ein kompletter Witz, ne, ne, ne, aber das speicher
ich mir mal, gut, dass du mir das geschickt hast, das ist ein optimaler Kandidat für das
nächste Video, wir sind richtig agil unterwegs, ihr Profil, haben die auch sowas was sie bieten,
die Michael Schmidt, also ihr Profil, abgeschlossene Berufsausbildung, ok, ausgeprägene blablabla,
professioneller Umgang mit Menschen, finde ich gut, dass sie das reinschreiben, wahrscheinlich
versteht ihr nämlich da was anderes drunter als ich, und nachdem da schon der Umgang mit
Menschen drin steht, würde ich mal sagen, das ist definitiv kein Beruf für mich, ich
glaube auch nicht, dass der Laden sonderlich groß ist, ja, guck mal mal, das heißt übrigens
auch by the way, nur wenn ich die Stellenanzeige schlecht finde, heißt das noch nicht, dass
die Firma schlecht ist, es gibt einfach welche, es gibt gute Firmen, die es einfach nicht
auf die Reihe kriegen, irgendwie ordentliche Stellenanzeigen zu schreiben, über uns, das
sieht mit Dark Reader echt nicht gut aus die Seite, Kokona, Kokona Rezession, ja wie viel
Mitarbeiter haben sie jetzt, steht das da irgendwo, ne, ja gut, so was wollen die sonst
noch, sehr guter Umgang, ok, das ist, das haben sie doch hier oben schon geschrieben,
schnelle Auffassung, Teamfähigkeit, Teamfähigkeit und Belastbarkeit, also ich bin da mittlerweile
immer ein bisschen getriggert, wenn sowas drin steht, also mit Teamfähigkeit finde ich,
finde ich ok, dass es drin steht, aber Belastbarkeit, es, ganz ehrlich, es geht doch nicht drum,
dass man die Leute irgendwie maximal ausbeuten kann für wenig Geld und irgendwie denke ich
da immer instinktiv dran, auch wenn das wahrscheinlich viele gar nicht so meinen, die das reinschreiben,
aber ich denke da instinktiv immer dran, wenn ich, wenn ich sowas lese, so nach dem Motto,
wir wollen den Leuten nichts bezahlen wollen, aber dass sie quasi bis am Limit arbeiten,
am besten noch 30 Milliarden Überstunden machen und am Ende nichts dafür kriegen, ja, man
sollte den Job länger als zwei Jahre machen können, ohne dass man danach im Arsch ist.
Idealerweise verfügen sie über relevante Herstellungszertifizierungen, Microsoft,
VM, Ok, Backup ist dann anscheinend VM und nicht TSM, Alles klar, Führerschein Klasse
B, Erfahrung in der Arbeit mit einem Ticketsystem, natürlich, Gyra, Alter, Gyra, Gyra, Erfahrung,
beste, beziehungsweise eines der wenig erträglichen, oh das, das ist gut, der Chainlock ist wieder
am Katzen freistellen, Leute, was ist besser, das oder das, was ich schon unten habe, das
was ich unten habe passt halt besser, das was ich unten habe passt halt besser, das hast
aber ein gutes Bild erwischt, Reihe Katze 2, ich speicher mir das mal, so, also was bieten
sie denn, was bieten sie denn, was, warum man da hingehen sollte, übrigens, brauchen
wir noch ein bisschen Pool Sounds, Leute, ich mache jetzt keine drei Stunden an dem Katzen
Pool Bild rum, also was bieten sie denn, die Stellenaufschreiben wurde über Xing geschickt,
ja bei Xing, Xing, ich dachte Xing ist tot, ich dachte alle verwenden nur noch LinkedIn,
da sind irgendwelche Headhunter Typen, die fette Profition kriegen von einem ersten Jahresgehalt
oder drei Monats Geld oder was auch immer und die schicken dir alles in der Hoffnung,
was du da unterschreibst, ok, also was haben die denn hier, vielseitige abwängsreie Hauswohnung,
das ist ja kein, das ist nicht wirklich ein Vorteil, unbefristet Arbeitsvertrag, ja gut,
hey, jetzt mal ernsthaft, jetzt mal ernsthaft, KegWayne, wenn ich jemand finden würde, wenn
ich Michael Schmidt wäre und jemand finden würde, der das alles kann, für das was man
wahrscheinlich ja Geld bekommt, dem würde ich auch sofort einen unbefristeten Arbeitsvertrag
mit mindestens 15 Jahre Laufzeiten unterschieben, den will ich nämlich nie wieder hergeben,
wenn ich da echt jemand finde, flexible durch flache Hierarchien, gut, das kann jetzt gut
oder schlecht sein, mein weißes, 15 Jahre Arbeitsverträgen geht natürlich logischerweise
nett, aber den würde ich definitiv sofort mir krallen, den Typ, LinkedIn ist wie Tinder
nur andersrum, junge Frauen schreien Matile an, bekommen keine Antwort, jetzt recht, da
hast du recht, true, true, null W, das habe ich so noch gar nicht gesehen, ja, ey, der
Witz ist, ich kann es euch nicht zeigen, ich habe den Account nicht, wahrscheinlich ist
er gelöscht, mein Fake-LinkedIn-Account, sowohl Peter Aguilé als auch Herr Wublé haben
beide Anfragen bekommen und Freundschaftsrequests auf LinkedIn, da sieht man mal wie unsinnig
diese Spam-Mails da sind, bestimmt von Zuschauern, ne, ne, ich habe mir die, von Zuschauern
auch, ich habe mir die Profile angeguckt, das sind halt so Leute, die haben dann irgendwie
40.000 Follower und vollen 40.000 Leuten, da waren sogar indische, ohne Mist, indische
CTOs Leute und so dabei, wahrscheinlich von irgendwo zwei Mann-Klitsche, ja, die da einfach
schreiben hier, Biggest Indian Big Brain Company CTO und ich habe aber auch ein paar Job-Angebote
bekommen, weil man dafür nicht vergessen, Herr Aguilé war, ich habe es schon wieder
vergessen, wartet mal, Cloud-Native-DevOps-Engineer-Specialist-Chief-Technology-Officer oder sowas,
Moment, Moment, was, Leute, ich gucke mir die Sachen gleich an, die ihr geschickt habt,
Leute, ich sehe eure, die Chebatelinks, Alter, die Chebatelinks bringen dich, ich kann drüber
hoffern mit der Maus und sehen, was dahinten, dahinter ist.
Und wer mich schafft zu Chebaten, da kriegt ihr erstmal einen Timeout, wenn es mir nicht
gefällt, was hinter dem Chebatelinks ist, ich habe keine Zeit für gerade, so, also was
war denn Herr Aguilé nochmal, zeig mal hier, Stellenanzeigen-Review, ah hier, hier, nein,
nein, stopp, Cloud, also wir waren Cloud-Native-Agile-GitOps-Solution-Chief-Engineer-Officer, so, kein Wunder,
kein Wunder, dass er da Jobangebote bekommen hat, ich meine, der hat ja mal alle Buzzwords
drinne, die irgendwie möglich sind, also mehr, mehr Buzzwords packst du da ein, ich glaube,
mehr ging in das Feld gerade einzutragen, wo ich chat, guck ich mal klar an, so, so,
das ist immer so ein Ding, für mich ist das kein Vorteil, ich hasse solche offiziellen
nicht Pflichtanstaltungen, also, wie soll ich sagen, offizielle Veranstaltungen, die
nicht verpflichtend sind, aber irgendwie doch, das finde ich doof, das sollte man einfach
jedem freistellen und dann auch irgendwie den Leuten nicht nahe legen, so nach dem
Motto, ja ist ja freiwillig, aber wenn du nicht kommst, ist auch doof, ich bin aber
auch jemand, der geht nicht zur Weihnachtsfeier, ähm, das ist Geschmackssache, es gibt Leute,
die finden das super geil, ich bin da nicht normal, was das angeht, wie gesagt, äh,
zwischenmenschliche Sachen ist nicht so meins, ich hab ja schon öfters mal die, kommt die
Anzeige ins nächste Video, also, bei denen bin ich mir gar nicht, bei denen bin ich mir
relativ sicher, dass ich die reinpacken werde, ja, ähm, so, zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel,
also eine Sache, wo sie mich auch richtig mitgeschockt haben ist, wir haben mal an einem
Projekt mitgearbeitet, das ist aber eine Lüge, das Weihnachtsparty Grill, ja, das ist ewig
her, das Weihnachtsparty Grill, da wo ich so richtig verkackt hab, das stimmt, da war
ich auf der Weihnachtsfeier, vielleicht gehe ich deswegen auch nicht mehr auf Weihnachtsfeiern,
ne, das ist mir aber erst später klar geworden, das wusste ich damals ja gar nicht, also,
wo sie mich mal richtig geschockt haben ist, wo man halt sieht, dass so die, die Ansicht
von Projektmanagern und IT Leuten durchaus auseinandergehen können, ist folgendes, wir
haben aber bei einem Projekt beteiligt, und der Projektleiter hat sich halt so richtig
gefreut, dass fertig ist, alles funktioniert hat, und meinte dann zu uns so, oh Leute, jetzt
machen wir was richtig geiles zum Abschluss mit dem ganzen Team, und da haben wir uns
schon so angeguckt, gedacht, äh, ohje, was ist jetzt los, wenn der was hat, was geiles
ist, und dann meinte er auf einmal, ich hab das jetzt durchgeboxt, oder ich boxt das jetzt
durch, dass da Budget für locker gemacht wird, und dann fahren wir alle zusammen in den Kletterpark.
Und so, da haben wir dann so da gesetzt, Kekwade, der will nicht wirklich mit uns in den Kletterpark
fahren, nicht in den Kletterpark, hatte ich keinen Bock drauf, aber ich weiß, dass es
genug Leute gibt, dieses Cool Fenton, ja, so, und was haben wir am Ende gemacht, was haben
wir am Ende gemacht, wir haben ihm das irgendwie soweit umschrieben, dass das nichts für uns
ist, am Ende sind wir einfach alle zu einer normalen Uhrzeit ordentlich fressen gegangen.
Das war aber auch gut, mit kostenlos Getränke, auch, äh, teureren Cocktailsachen, war eigentlich
echt nice, Essen größer Klettern aber eindeutig, und da hab ich mich richtig voll gefuddert,
massiv voll gefuddert, hier ist noch eine Stelle für dich, ja, die hast du schon 50
mal geschrieben, die hab ich schon offen, die gucken wir uns gleich noch an, ok, exellent,
exellent, ist das, ist das, ist das Michael Schmidt hier, ah, alles klar, Kona-Style,
also die Stellenanzeige nehme ich ins nächste Video, die ist Paint-Champ-ig genug, aber
by the way, sagt nichts wirklich Negatives über die Firma, manche können sowas einfach
nicht, ähm, zumindest nicht ansprechend, genauso wie Computer-Fuzzi, ist auch so eine
Anzeige, die find ich echt, echt Paint-Champ, ja, Kletterpark ist aber gesünder als Essen,
das ist richtig, da kann ich gar nichts dagegen sagen, aber wenn ich klettern gehen will,
dann mach ich das allein und nicht mit den Leuten von der Arbeit, geh ich lieber wandern,
Leute, nice, dass ihr so viele Paint-Champ-Stellenanzeige habt, so, jetzt gucken wir uns die Stellenanzeige
an, von, äh, wir haben das jetzt geschickt, Matsi, exellent, zeige ich mal her, also,
nee, das hatten wir doch gerade schon, wait a minute, nee, das war was anderes, oder?
Nee, Moment, die Seite sieht einfach nur übelst ähnlich aus, keck wait, Moment, wo, wo, wo
ist da, wo ist da Michael Schmidt, hab ich den noch?
Okay, nee, so ähnlich sehen die Seiten übrigens gar nicht aus, vielleicht auf den ersten
Blick so, wenn man so pepega ist wie ich, also, bewirb dich nicht bei uns, exellent,
wenn du Lust auf, äh, langweilige Projekte, inkompetente Vorgesetzten und dienstnah Vorschriften
hast, okay, das ist, auf der einen Seite ist es mal was anderes, auf der anderen Seite
ist es was anderes, aber, wisst ihr was ich noch cooler finden würde, wenn man einfach
schreiben würde, warum man so ein geiler Laden ist, wie so im Pool, weil das grad voll
angesagt ist, man macht alles im Pool auf Twitch grade, funny, aber lädt doch nicht
zum Bewerben ein, ja, kann ich so nicht sagen, also ich find's jetzt auch nicht, dass sagen
ich, ha ha, lustig, ich bewirb mich, aber es ist auf jeden, es zieht auf jeden Fall
ein bisschen Aufmerksamkeit, ähm, auf sich, ja, okay, also, wenn du einen Job willst,
bei dem nur deine Skills zählen und du jeden Tag etwas neu lernen willst, dann komm zu
uns, nur meine Skills, okay, das heißt keine zwischenmenschliche Sachen, das ist schon
mal sehr gut, aber wahrscheinlich ist das nicht so, was heißt, wo ist der knappe Bikini,
ich hab gar keinen Bikini dran, das ist doch besser, wir schauen Systeme, was wir, nein,
wir bauen Systeme, die einfach funktionieren, jeden Tag, übrigens wisst ihr auch, was ein
System ist, was einfach funktioniert, was ich auch jeden Tag verwende, mein exzellentes
Klo mit Bobbesspülung und mittlerweile, ich weiß nicht, ob ich es euch schon mal gezeigt
hab, meine Heizungsauswertung verwende ich auch jeden Tag, auch ein äußerst exquisites
Tool, ähm, den Subbutton, na, den Subbutton, nicht, dass ich noch wirklich Resitas Cosplay
machen muss, aber der Abobutton ist natürlich auf, gerade auf YouTube, den Abobutton auf
YouTube, den sollte man tatsächlich jeden Tag verwenden, allerdings nur einmal, also
das ergibt keinen Sinn, weil dann deabonniert man ja wieder, zumindest meine Heizungsdashboard,
das verwende ich auch tatsächlich jeden Tag, wo ich genau nachvollziehen kann, was meine
Heizung im Keller macht, ja, Wassertemperatur, Brennerstatus, Kesseltemperatur, Abgastemperatur,
Pumpenaktivität und Fehlerstatus, exzellent, man sieht, ich hab das auch ganze schon ne
Weile laufen, aber ich glaube, ich behalte die Daten nur ein halbes Jahr, oder, ja, halbes
Jahr behalte ich die Daten bloß, aber, exzellent, wofür zur Hölle braucht man das, wenn deine
Heizung öfters mal Probleme hat, ist es echt nicht verkehrt zu sehen, was abgeht, und
auf der anderen Seite ist es einfach äußerst nice, sich das anzugucken, ich freu mich dann
jedes Mal, wie gut mein selbst gebasteltes Dashboard und mein selbst gebastelte Auswertung
von der, äh, Auslesen von der Heizung funktioniert, wie kannst du hinter deinem Router ein valides
SSL-Zertifikat haben, das ist eine exzellente Frage, und das ist gar nicht so schwer, man
macht letztendlich mit DNS-Challenge, du kaufst dir ne Domain, und, äh, für 2,50, ich hab
gehört, COM-Domains sind übelst billig mittlerweile, aber ich hab ne Punkt-Haus-Domain, die war
auch billig, der Heizungs-Monteur wollte mir die offizielle Sache vom Hersteller verkaufen,
da hab ich ihm am Dashboard gezeigt, und da hat er gemeint, ne, dann brauch ich die ja
nicht, der fand's auch nicht schlecht, ähm, markend, ja, so geht's, ne, genau, also du
kaufst dir ne Domain, irgendwas, dann nimmst du dir ein Tool für Let's Encrypt, was dir
ne DNS-Challenge kann, und machst dann DNS-Challenge, lokal, äh, mit Let's Encrypt für deine exzellente
Domain, und dann kannst du dir auch für lokal laufende Dinger, wie gesagt, ihr könnt das
nicht auflösen von außen oder so, dann kannst du dir auch lokale, äh, gültige lokale Zertifikate
machen, ja.
Also, das sollten wir uns jetzt angucken, machen wir jetzt, TGSP, mach mal Ausrufezeichen,
ah ja, gut, da hat ja schon einer gemacht, okay, also gucken wir uns das Ganze jetzt mal
an, Ausbildung, Fachinformatiker, oh, guck mal, ne neuer Fachinformatikerberuf, das ist
das erste Mal, dass ich das sehe, das hab ich noch nie gesehen, Fachinformatiker in
digitale Vernetzung, Wahnsinn, ich wusste gar nicht, dass das überhaupt jemand verwendet,
okay, Lies bei unseren Stellenanzeigen, Fachinformatiker, äh, what, oh, okay, die wollen echt krampferflustig
sein, ja, verstehe, Painz, bisschen Painz-Champing ist es schon, aber wisst ihr was ich an denen
denk, wisst ihr was ich cool finde, wo die bei mir echt Pluspunkte machen, dass sie Emojis
in der Anzeige verwenden, das ist schon mal ein Pluspunkt, ja, und nicht so dummes Smiley,
sondern richtig echte Lach-Emojis, Emoji-Supporter, okay, unsere Azubis lernen etwas, nicht nur,
dass sie, was, nicht nur das, achso, unsere Azubis lernen etwas, nicht nur das, sie sind
nach ihrer Ausbildung echte Waffen, das ist schon echt Painz-Champing die Anzeige, Alter,
jetzt muss ich mir auch speichern, die sind so geil, die Dinger, die ihr hier schickt,
die muss ich ins nächste Video hauen, Cringe, ja, Cringe, aber richtig Cringe, ähm, weil
sie etwas lernen und ihre Abschlussprüfung bestehen, hey, okay, mal ganz im Ernst, also
um die IHK-Abschlussprüfung zu bestehen, da gehört nicht viel dazu, am besten ist,
man bereitet sich mit alten Prüfungen auf die neue Prüfung vor, da muss man von dem
Beruf gar keine Ahnung haben, also IHK-Abschlussprüfung bedeutet mir einfach gar nichts, du willst
auch eine echte Waffe, oh, das tut so weh, das ist schrecklich zu lesen, du willst auch
eine echte Waffe sein, dann komm zu uns und lerne mehr über Windows-Surfer-Active-Directory-Exchange,
dazu kann ich bloß sagen, oh, wenn hab ich ein kurzes Emoji oder irgendwie sowas, hab
ich nicht, dazu kann ich bloß sagen, gehst du mal fort, Windows-Surfer-Active-Directory-Exchange,
äh, igitt, was wurde bei deiner IHK-Prüfung, das weiß ich doch jetzt nicht mehr, das war
eine typische IHK-Prüfung, das war eine 0a15-IHK-Prüfung, also Windows-Surfer-Active-Directory,
da kannst du mich jagen mit, Linux, Ubuntu, CentOS, sorry Leute, Ubuntu hab ich ja wieder
falsch ausgeräumt, Jubantu, ich glaube, dass sie mein Projekt damals auch nicht verstanden
hatten, was hast du für ein Projekt gemacht, SaberFZ, dankeschön, zwei Monate Subscription,
huge Subs hier, wieder, Subscriptions, high IQ-Subscriptions, Wupplan hat auch abonniert,
hab ich nicht gesehen, dankeschön für den Sub, und MaliTTV, falls ich nicht vorgelesen
hab, dankeschön auch für den Sub, also gleich, gleich müssen wir umschalten für den Chat,
5-Hat zu 6-Hat, so viel IQ-Increase, wie es heute gab, das würde ich der IHK gar nicht
mehr unterstellen, dass sie das nicht verstehen, Leute, ich scroll jetzt mal, was ist mit meinem
Chat los, warum ist der Chat da oben, da hab ich überhaupt nicht aufgehört zu lesen,
ok ich hoffe, ich hab nix übersehen, passt, sind wir wieder unten, ok jetzt erst mal schnell
da gucken, also sorry for Bash, excellent, warum Bash, warum nicht ZSH, so also was machen
die sonst noch, also da wär ich dabei, da wär ich dabei, Linux Ubuntu CentOS, oh hier,
was, hallo Max, ich bin einer deiner Viewer auf YouTube, so wie du mit Wohnsitz in Frankfurt,
ich bin ja nicht direkt in Frankfurt, ich bin aber in der Nähe, das Internet hier sackt,
ja kann ich mir vorstellen, zumindest je nachdem wo man ist, zumindest abends, wenn viele im
Haus in der Umgebung online sind, dann bekomme ich ein Highping, was hast du, Vodafone oder
vielleicht sogar LTE oder sowas, Highping und Soap macht damit keinen Spaß, wir haben,
iiih, Telekom Hybrid, ja da dran liegt's, wir haben Internet über Kabel, ah nee, nee,
da dran liegt's, bringt es einfach, du wolltest auf den Business-Tarif umzustellen, eher nicht,
das ist jetzt ja auch alles Vodafone, das ist auch alles Vodafone, sonst vielleicht
auf DSL wechseln, kriegt damit seine Einladung oder auch, also Hybrid ist mega Sack, Hybrid,
also überall wo LTE dabei ist oder Funktion, vergiss es, das ist einfach Müll, lass das,
lass es nicht, DSL ist auf jeden Fall eine Überlegung, wenn es da was Gescheites bei
euch gibt, da hast du weniger Probleme, zumindest im Durchschnitt, man kann das jetzt schlecht
sagen, vielleicht verkacken sie es auch bei euch direkt dann richtig, aber im Durchschnitt
dürftest du mit DSL weniger Probleme haben und der Business-Tarif bringt, von dem was
ich gehört hab, ich kann da leider nicht aus erster Hand von berichten, nix, VDSL 250,
ja das reicht doch, wobei ich Vodafone mit 1G schon nice finde, wenn es dann halt auch
bei 1G gibt, Hybrid ist Sack, Alter, Hybrid ist ja echt Probleme vorprogrammiert, Amazon
sucht einen Teamleiter IT-Support, exzellent, nice, so also was haben die sonst noch hier
zu bieten, also ich mach das jetzt mal im Schnelldurchgang, IT-Sicherheit und Pen-Testing,
das ist was von den Twinko, kann ja gleich hier Big Stonks machen, Sicherheitslücken
finden für Fame, find ich cool, dass sie das so schreiben, ey die Stellenanzeige ist
so painstampig, dass es schon langsam nicht mehr weh tut, wisst ihr, es ist so viel Pain,
dass es schon wieder okay ist, Netzwerktechnik, Routing, Switches und Firewall, wie man brave
Kunden glücklich macht, wie man doofe Kunden abwimmelt, wie man alle möglichen Geräte
hier zum Laufen bekommt, oh man, Pain, dass das tut, oh please, ja der Cyclomedia, guck
schon mal klein an, IT-Administrator, ja mir fehlt jetzt noch so ein bisschen der Punkt,
warum man da wirklich hin will, dass ich meine, schöne, schöne, nenn es mal lustige Sachen
schreiben, was haben die denn geiles, dass man da hin will, das wüsste ich jetzt nicht
so genau, okay jetzt muss ich unbedingt die Werbung machen von Cyclomedia, weil es postet
hier der Ultra Chaos schon eine halbe Stunde, Werkstudentin, was nur Frauen triggert, Alter,
für den technischen Support, Werkstudenten für den technischen Support, okay, Cyclomedia
sucht dich, du hast Lust in einem jung und dynamischen Team den technischen Support zu
unterstützen, gibt es irgendjemand, der da Lust drauf hat, gibt es wirklich jemand, der
da Lust drauf hat, seid ihr auch schon mal morgens aufgewacht und habt gesagt, jawoll,
ich hätte so Bock drauf, einem jungen und dynamischen Team im technischen Support zu
helfen, also wer hatte das noch nicht, ich hab das laufend, ich glaube, es gibt niemand,
der das hat, okay dich erwarten abwechslungsreiche Aufgabe im technischen Support, die Möglichkeit
entschreib dich auch mal zu ver- oh das ist aber nett, okay das nicht, also bis hierhin
hab ich mir noch gedacht, Post-Champ, Post-Champ und dann hab ich gelesen, mit so Kundenterminen
zu fahren und dann ist es von Post-Champ zu Pains-Champ umgeschwenkt.
Black Siebler Amalzeit mit der Möglichkeit teilweise im Homeoffice zu arbeiten, okay,
das finde ich schon mal ganz gut, dass man es zumindest Erwähnung findet in der aktuellen
Zeit, flache Hierarchien und eine attraktive Vergütung, ähm, Aufgaben, die typischen
Aufgaben des technischen Supports am deutschen Standort Wetzlar, oh in Wetzlar, ich glaube
in Wetzlar musste ich für meinen Zivildienst so nen, so nen, in Anführungsstrichen Seminar
besuchen, das war das letzte Mal, jetzt kein Witz Leute, das letzte Mal in meinem Leben,
wo ich so richtig besoffen war, nie wieder danach, so extrem.
In Wetzlar gibt es so ne, für, da gibt es eben so ne zentrale Zivildienst, fragt mich
nicht, Zivildienst, äh, Seminarstelle oder so, das ist mit Übernachten und wenn du halt
nen Haufen, äh, sag mal mal 18 bis 25, höchstens 25-Jährigen da irgendwie zusammenhockst,
was machen die denn abends, die besorfen sich, also das war das letzte Mal echt, wo ich richtig
krass besoffen war, aber so richtig hardcore, also ich hab auch alle möglichen Sachen durcheinander
gesorfen und so, kein Wunder, und am anderen Tag hatten wir nen Seminar, ich weiß noch
heute, das Seminar hieß, wohin marschiert die Bundeswehr, wo ich mich so frage, was
zum Teufel, warum mache ich denn Zivildienst alter, wenn mich das interessiert, wohin die
Bundeswehr marschiert, und mir war es so schlecht, als ich da drinnen gesessen hab, ich muss
zwischendurch echt rausrennen auf den Klo und ich weiß noch, wie sich die Leute dabei
lustig gemacht haben, und haben schon gemeint, Alter, das ist so langweilig, hier gucken
sie mal da, ihnen rennen schon die Leute weg, ja, aber das war das letzte Mal, wo ich mir
echt, wo ich so richtig am Arsch war, wenigstens gekotzt hab, wenn es bei gekotzt geblieben
wäre, Alter, das war echt Monarch-ess, das an dem Tag, und ich hab auch den Fehler gemacht,
ich hab abends alle möglichen Sachen durcheinander gesoffen, von Wodka bis Sangria, das ist
richtig, und dann hab ich nachts erstmal ordentlich gereiert, und morgens hab ich einen der größten
Fehler meines Lebens begangen, ich hatte mega Hunger, und mega Durst, so wie das halt so
mal vorkommt, und dann hab ich morgens beim Frühstück erstmal Schnitzelbrötchen gefuttert,
und das war der größte Fehler, und ich glaub fast zwei eiskalte Sprite getrunken, und danach
endlich instant kotzen können, dann war vorbei, also die kalte Sprite auf den Magen war echt
einfach weg, und dann war vorbei, oh man, das war noch Zeit, ja, da war der Max noch
nicht Boomer, da hatte auch noch kaum einer nen Handy und bezüglich schweigern, den Smartphone
gab's noch gar nicht, das muss, lasst mal überlegen, das muss so 2000, warte mal, ich
bin 1984 geboren, ich weiß es schockiert die Leute immer, aber ist so, ich bin 1984 geboren,
das heißt 16 war ich 2000, dann war ich 19, 20, lass es mal 2003 gewesen sein, 2003 oder
so war das, da hatte noch keiner nen Smartphone, richtig Boomer, sag ich doch immer, ihr glaubt
mir das bloß nicht, da gab es, da gab es schon keine D-Mark mehr, aber es könnte noch
Übergangsphase gewesen sein, da bin ich mir nicht mehr ganz sicher, ob es da noch Übergangsphase
gab, 2001 war Euro, ja, aber das ging ja irgendwie dann, ne gewisse Zeit, wo du beides verwenden
konntest und so, ach, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau, aber ich sag euch mal eine Sache,
aber ohne Scheiß, und das ist jetzt nicht diese typische, diese typische Sache, da wo
ich jung war, ich sag euch mal ohne Scheiß, ich bin jetzt ja mit 36 auch noch nicht wahnsinnig
alt, die 90er und 2000er, aber eher die 90er, das geile da dran war, das war komplett,
so komplett YOLO Jahrgang, also sprich, da konntest du alles machen und es hat nicht
gleich jemand geheult, so wie heute, das fand ich, das war so ne richtig geile, uns ist
alles scheißegal in den 90ern, und es waren nicht nur Leute in meinem Alter, das waren
irgendwie alle, auch die älteren, die haben alle, das hat alle, nichts hat irgendjemand
gejuckt, ja, damals hat man noch gedacht, 2020 fliegen wir mit Autos durch die Straßen
und sowas, da waren die Leute nicht instant triggered bei jedem Scheiß, ja, vor 10 Jahren
war es auch noch nicht ganz so schlimm, aber heute ist ja wirklich Dauertrigger-Alarm
auf Twitch, nicht auf Twitch, auf Twitter, naja, aber 90er waren einfach nice in der
Richtung, heute ist, heute ist, es gab damals auch genug Leute, die sich über jeden Scheiß
aufgeregt haben, ja, beispielsweise mein damaliger Nachbar, der immer gesagt hat, die Leute dürfen
auf dem Rasen nicht Fußball spielen, ich war halt auch einer, der das machen wollte
damals, du hattest auch viele, ganz viele, wie man heute sagen würde, haha, alte weiße
Männer, aber wisst ihr, wisst ihr was wir gemacht haben damals, wir haben uns darüber
lustig gemacht und haben es trotzdem gemacht, wir haben uns einfach darüber lustig gemacht,
wir waren nicht ultra triggered 3 Stunden und haben geflennt, sondern haben einfach gesagt
Scheiß drauf, damals, damals war Twitch noch Justintv, genau, ne, das gab es damals noch
nicht, aber trotzdem, das war das Geile in den 90ern, es war nicht jeder wegen jedem
Scheiß ultra triggered, ich sage nicht, dass es unberechtigt ist heute in manchen Fällen,
aber es wird einfach total übertrieben aktuell, naja, so, dann gucken wir uns die ganze Sache
mal kurz weiter an, also, ok, Leute, es hört schon mal damit auf, wenn ich das erste, was
ich mir durchlese ist, First Level Kundensupport, also Kundensupport und First Level in Kombination
und ist ja oftmals in Kombination, ist, da ist vorbei, dazu kann ich nur sagen, Aristomat,
das sind gar nicht so sehr die Jugendlichen, die so krass getriggert sind, denen geht es
glaube ich auch zum größten Teil auf den Sack, du hast da ein paar von, aber ich glaube,
die hauptsächlich, die hauptsächliche Altersgruppe, die so richtig krass triggered ist bei jedem
Scheiß auf Twitter, das sind die in meinem Alter und ein bisschen jünger, also sagen
wir mal so, die Altersgruppe von 25 bis 40, das sind so die richtig krassen getriggerten,
von den Jugendlichen heutzutage, ganz ehrlich, ich bin jetzt natürlich nicht so, da nicht
so drin, was das angeht, da, die machen sich darüber lustig, so wie wir das früher gemacht
haben, wir haben uns früher auch darüber lustig gemacht, wenn der Opa am Fenster gestanden
hat und kein Fußball spielen oder sowas, die meisten Jugendlichen machen sich da lustig
darüber und wenn die was sagen, dann zumindest so wie ich das sehe, ich bin ja auch nur Zuschauer
auf Twitter, dann ist da auch meistens was dran, also die erkennen schon ziemlich gut
den Unterschied zwischen einfach nur grundlos empört und es ist wirklich was dran.
Okay, jetzt lass uns das mal ganz schnell kurz, Twitter Trends gucke ich mir auch gar
nicht mehr an, Twitter Trends, ich hab mein Twitter auf Andorra stehen, weil ich mir den
ganzen Kram, gerade Twitter Deutschland, wobei Twitter International ist da nicht besser,
ich kann mir das nicht mehr geben.
Zepcon, da musst du dir keine Gedanken drüber machen, ich dachte mir nämlich auch, als ich
gesagt hab, geil Computer finde ich interessant und endlich kann man online spielen, ich hab
im Modern Half Life online gespielt und sowas, da hab ich mir gedacht, Leute wie geil ist
das, ohne Mist hab ich mir echt gedacht, was trendet in Andorra, nix, die schreiben nix
in Andorra, ich dachte mir damals echt, wie geil muss es sein, quasi in meinem Alter in
20, das hab ich mir damals wirklich gedacht, ich hab gedacht, wie cool das sein muss, so
in 20 Jahren in diesem Alter zu sein und Internet und Technik ist überall komplett da und sonst
wieder, hab ich natürlich nicht mit dem Breitbandausbau in Deutschland gerechnet, aber besser
als modern ist es natürlich, nur eine Sache hab ich damals maßlos überschätzt, ich bin
eigentlich davon ausgegangen, dass Jugendliche, Kinder, Jugendliche, junge Erwachsene in der
heutigen Zeit deutlich mehr grundsätzliche Technik-Skills haben, als ich mir das gedacht
hab, nee umgedreht, die Leute haben heute, ich hab das total überbewertet, ich dachte
mir die Leute haben viel mehr Technik-Skills als es heute wirklich der Fall ist, bei denen
du in den Settings kannst du es umstellen, aber man muss mal ehrlich sagen, wenn ich
mir das so angucke und auch teilweise wenn ich mir die Kommentare unter YouTube-Videos
wo sowas geht durchlese, muss ich sagen, die haben eigentlich von so grundlegenden technischen
Sachen, wie die funktionieren, absolut keine Ahnung und ich glaube das liegt daran, weil
man sich da heute mit nicht beschäftigen muss, du musst heute nix mehr zusammenbauen, nix
mehr konfigurieren, du musst nicht mal großartig wissen, wie Sachen funktionieren, Internet,
Anschlussgedöns ist so einfach wie nie, du musst eigentlich gar nichts mehr wirklich
wissen und dazu kommt, dass die Leute auch irgendwie nicht mehr in der Lage sind richtig
zu suchen und ich dachte die Leute heute in dem Alter machen das easy as fuck alles, es
ist unglaublich, ich hätte früher den Leuten wirklich mehr zugetraut von Technik-IT-Knowhow
zu haben, was die Leute natürlich wunderbar können ist sich, was weiß ich, mit Smartphone-Geschichten
auskennen und ich glaube viele Leute können heute auch instinktiv relativ gut erkennen,
was ist Scam und was kann man ernst nehmen, was ist Fake News und so, da haben die sicherlich
bessere Skills als Leute, die da mit meinem Alter Internet-Sachen angefangen haben, aber
so rein mit Technik-Basics, wie Sachen funktionieren, wie man Sachen ganz macht, wenn sie mal nicht
funktionieren, haben die Leute heute im Prinzip genauso wenig wie vorher, das heißt unsere
Jobs sind im Endeffekt gesichert.
Auf Facebook sehen eh nur noch Leute älter als ich drauf, niemand verwendet ja mal Facebook,
okay also wir gucken jetzt echt diese Einstell-Anzeige mal fertig, da wird ja heute gar nicht mehr
auf heute, also wo sind wir stehen geblieben, ne nicht Computer-Fuzzi, ah Paintschamp, Moment
das haben wir uns auch noch nicht angeguckt, Paintschamp wo bin ich denn stehen geblieben,
nicht Computer-Fuzzi, sondern Werkstudent, also das schlimmste ist schon mal hier First-Level-Kundensupport,
habe ich gar keinen Bock drauf, Zapcorn Dankeschön für den Sub, Exquisite-Subscription, Leute
wir haben heute ungefähr 150 mehr Zuschauer als sonst, das liegt denke ich mal einzig
und allein am Pool-Stream-Meter oder, bisschen geplätscher, yep ich würde sagen wir machen
als öfters Pool-Stream wenn das so gut reinhaut, Indie-Max, okay Kommunikation im internationalen
Support-Team, Second-Level, ja Moment was machst du jetzt, machst du First-Level, machst du
Second-Level, achso du kommunizierst mit dem Second-Level, okay das ist schon mal Paintschamp-ig,
also das ganze ist da, Second-Level ist wahrscheinlich zu kommunizieren ist nicht das Problem, erstellen
von Demo-Anwendung auf Basis der Unternehmens, Moment was, okay das passt jetzt, das passt
jetzt nicht so wirklich zusammen, Verarbeitung von geografischen Daten, Vektor, what, was
what, okay, okay Moment, Moment, Moment, also es ist ein Werkstudent für den technischen
Support, technischer Support ist das erste was sie hier beschreiben ja, okay aber das
ist auch noch okay, Erstellung von Demo-Anwendung auf Basis der Unternehmens internen API gehört
da absolut nicht rein, das hat nichts mit Support, vor allem wie soll das ein Werkstudent
machen, was ist denn First-Level-Support mit Java, ich hab keine Ahnung, was sie da genau
wollen, kein Schimmer, First-Level-Support ist eigentlich eher sowas in der Richtung
wie Hilfe mein Server ist abgestürzt wenn du beim Provider arbeitest oder keine Ahnung
Hilfe mein Windows ist abgestürzt wenn du Endkunden-Support hast, aber ja nicht das
gut, aber das ist schon mal Fail, aber was zum Geier ist das, Verarbeitung von geografischen
Daten, Vektor-Daten, Verschneiden, Vereinen, Einfach, Analysen, Längenberechnung, Transformat,
was zum Teufel das hat doch damit absolut gar nichts zu tun, vor allem was soll uns
das überhaupt sagen, Stunks, Unterstützung des Vertriebsteams, das kann ich doch irgendwie
verstehen und dann kommt jetzt noch der Hammer oben drauf, der Hammer oben drauf für einen
Werkstudent technischer Support, Vorbereitung und Durchführung von Kundenpräsentationen,
das würde ich jetzt von jemand der Support-Mitarbeit, Werkstudent im Support ist nicht erwarten
dass der eine Kundenpräsentation macht, ja, Durchführung von, ok, da kann man sagen
das ergibt noch Sinn, mal allgenommen man ist echt im Support, kennt sich mit dem Thema
gut aus und schulte ein paar Leute drin, das ergibt noch Sinn, also das ist ok, aber das
hier, das ist kompletter Müll, komplett, komplett random, wir, hat damit überhaupt
nichts zu tun, Anforderungen, schau da mal was es für eine Firma ist, ob das dann mehr
Sinn ergibt, bin ich mir unschlüssig, erfasst Daten aus der kleinen Wand, wandeln sie in
wertvolle Einblicke um, auf diese Weise, ah das ist deswegen, deswegen machen die ihre
geografischen Dinger, ja, Office, Official Dark, der Link geht nicht, muss man Shortlink
draus machen, ok, die machen irgendwelche Street View Geschichten oder sowas, aber trotzdem,
du kannst doch keinen suchen der im Support arbeitet und nebenbei noch wollen, dass der
Anwendung programmiert, irgendwelche komischen Dinger macht, wo ich keine Ahnung vorhabe
was es ist und noch irgendwelche Kundenpräsentationen, hallo es geht um den Werkstudent im technischen
Support, der macht auch keine Kundenpräsentationen für irgendwelche Produkte von dem Laden,
das passt nicht zusammen, so, also was braucht man, Kenntnis in Webprogrammierung, JavaScript
und HTML, exzellent, und C sharp, und C sharp, braucht man, C sharp, es sind die Subgoals,
echt, genauso echt wie mein Instagram, wie mein Instagram Account auch, Instagram Account
auch, wie man auch in die Fans Account, gegebenenfalls, ja, also was braucht man, Kenntnisse, Bereitschaft
zu Kunden, Kenntnisse in Office, Teamfähigkeit, gut Englisch, kein Must have, Kenntnisse
in C sharp, grundlegende Giz Kenntnisse, ok, das ist irgendwelche Street View Geschichten,
und wie viel gibt es, 450 Euro, ok, also wenn man weiß was sie machen, ergibt es schon
teilweise Sinn, aber ganz ehrlich, ich sehe, ich sehe das alles nicht bei einem Werkstudent
im technischen Support, ganz ehrlich nicht, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, Chalo, du könntest
lieber, bevor du irgendwelche komischen Bildchen machst, die ich vielleicht einmal im Stream
brauche, du könntest wieder nice Kixi-Modes machen, die sind auch echt Poggers, Leute,
ich sehe Rigroll-Emotes, sofort, Emotes-Klave, ja, es gibt Schlimmeres, oder, du könntest
auch Werkstudent für technischen Support sein und dann Kundenpräsentationen machen
müssen, nee, natürlich nur, wenn du Bock drauf hast, ne, kann ich dir mal ein Stellangebot
im Chat schicken, klar, hast du mal das hier gesehen, ok, ich guck's mir als nächstes
an, zeig her, nee, vorher müssen wir, ich mach das mal auf, vorher müssen wir uns noch
den hier angucken, den sollte ich mir schon vor 5 Stunden angucken, hab ich nicht gemacht,
den da, degradungsadministrator, MWD, schon wieder, nutzen sie den Freiraum, wir bieten
ihn, das hatten wir doch schon, seien sie willkommen, womit, das hatten wir doch schon,
aber wir haben das nie fertig geguckt, nee, sie beobachten technologische Trends, denken
Themen neu und fördern mit technologischer Kreativität, weil bla, bla, bla, bla, bla,
Blah Blah Blah Blah
Soll das überzeugt das jetzt wirklich irgendwie mal zu sagen da muss ich hin weil ich ich denke denke themen neu
Ja und
Technologischer kreativität
Das ist wirklich blass sie hat mir die administrieren die luftsystem auf basis von debian und slas ist das suzé suzé enterprise linux
Oh, please no god no god, please no no no no
Ne susé hätte gar keinen bock drauf
Sie sind verantwortlich für die konfiguration die updates und deployments mit java soll
Es war korrekt muss man ja kriegt java die coolen leute sprechen das natürlich java aus oder oder
Ja war nee
Spricht das glaube ich keine aus
Java ich persönlich bin ja ja war fan von der aussprache aber es gibt genug leute die sind der meinung es heißt java
java
Beidstrang's ich bin auch für java, java beste
So sie sind verantwortlich für die konfiguration die updates und deployments mit java
Tomcat, jabos und wild誕 ist doch auch nen java application server oder habe ich letztens gelernt nur durch stellanzeigen lesen
Sie betreuen sowohl unser Plesk Umgebung, Blablabla, Containerlösungen, Blablupf, sie
denken sich schnell und strukturiert in Prozesse hinein.
Das sind so Sätze, ohne Mist, das können sich nur entweder Personalleute oder irgendwelche
Big Stonks Management Leute ausdenken solche Sätze, was genau, was wollen die von einem,
wenn die sowas reinschreiben, natürlich das macht sich gut, wenn man dann sagen kann
ja und ich denke mich auch schnell und strukturiert in Prozesse hinein, aber was genau soll das
wirklich bedeuten und wenn man weiß, was es wirklich bedeuten soll, warum schreibt man
es da nicht einfach hin.
Die wollen wahrscheinlich sowas damit sagen, so man checkt relativ schnell wo es lang geht
auf gut Deutsch, ja also sprich man ist relativ findig raus zu bekommen oder relativ clever
raus zu bekommen, wie was funktioniert, aber man könnte es doch einfach auch hinschreiben.
Sie arbeiten selbstständig, handlungsorientiert und verantwortungsvoll, handlungsorientiert,
was genau bedeutet handlungsorientiert, vor allem meint ihr es gibt irgendjemand der
sagt oh nee, ich bin so verantwortungslos, ich bewerbe mich da jetzt nicht, hier nochmal
in Short die Anzeige, okay exellent, Technische Universität Dresden, boah, als PDF, jetzt
wollen sie es aber wissen, okay also naja, null, nicht so super spannend, so was soll
ich mir als nächstes angucken, das hatten wir uns schon angeguckt, achso man verdient
hier ja auch gar nichts bei denen oder, was verdient man dann eigentlich, die beabsichtige
Einkommen erfolgt je nach Unpersönlichkeit bis zur Entgeltgruppe 8, was ist, was ist,
was ist Entgeltgruppe TVL, E8, das ist wahrscheinlich nix oder, E8, ist das, ist das ernsthaft
proto im Monat, soll die mich verarschen, davon kannst du ja fast noch nicht mal auf
die Arbeit fahren, dann ist das weg, das kann doch nicht in Ernst sein, okay Moment, Moment,
das steigt, ah Moment, Moment, Moment, das geht noch höher, 1800 Euro Alter, ich mein
ihr müsst euch das mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, da verdient man im Monat weniger und
zwar deutlich weniger, als ich mit 4 Tage Woche und 14 Monats Gehältern, das kann doch nicht
verdienen, ich hab's ja im Stream schon mal gezeigt, müsst euch einfach den Tarifvertrag
angucken, Stufe 6, 14 Jahre, bloß ein bisschen was obendrauf, aber im Prinzip weiß mehr
oder weniger jeder, was ich verdiene, aber das ist halt echt der Witz, das Ding ist,
wenn du jetzt in Dresden, ach guck mal, da Frasier ist auch am Start, das ist aber nicht
in Dresden, das ist auch nicht im Osten, das ist glaub in Bayern und in Bayern ist es nicht
billig, das ist in Bayern und zwar in Erlangen, da kommst du damit wahrscheinlich, ja aber
ich mein du kannst doch nicht die Leute für echt komplett abel und ein Ei arbeiten lassen,
ja dann ist Rep, klar ist es immer, das sag ich ja auch, es ist immer abhängig davon
wo du bist, gerade IT Hessen Frankfurt ist natürlich das beste, aber the fuck, das ist
ja wirklich nix, Fabian wie sieht's aus, wann steigst du auch in das Poolstream Meta ein
auf Twitch, du könntest das doch ohne Probleme machen, easy, Frasier beim Baden, Blanch Blanch
easy subs, easy live, Behörden verdienst du nur, wenn du ein Studium vorzahlen könntest,
ja die sollen die Leute halt einfach mal angemessen bezahlen, weil da musst du dich auch nicht
beschweren, wenn da keiner hingeht, du wärtest, du wärtest was, VTuber, was ist denn Vtube,
ist das, ach das ist das, ach doch ich weiß was das ist, das ist das von, das ist das
Verschwörungs YouTube oder, das ist das Verschwörungs YouTube, das schreibt man aber doch, nee,
das ist wo du so ein Anime Avatar hast, der für dich redet, nee das kenne ich nicht,
das kenne ich wirklich nicht, ey das geht aber auch gut ab, ne, das geht auch gut ab,
es gibt gerade im, frag mich nicht warum ich das weiß, es gibt gerade im so, wie nennt
man das so, kein Ahnung, so Webcam, Webcam Girl Bereich, gibt's da mittlerweile echt
nen richtigen Hype in dieser Richtung, dass die alle als Anime Figur rumrennen und die
haben echt auf einen Schlag 8000 Zuschauer oder so, ja das stimmt, du brauchst eigentlich
nur, das ist eigentlich, das finde ich gar nicht mal so schlecht, ne, auf der einen Seite
Leute die richtig hot aussehen, die richtig geil aussehen und damit keine Probleme haben,
können sich hinstellen und mal zumindestens Pool Streaming, Boop Streaming oder im Zweifelsfall
wenn sie mit anderen Sachen kein Problem haben, Onlyfans, Pornhub, was auch immer machen,
ja, aber was machen Leute die nur eine gute Stimme haben oder eine süße Stimme haben
oder Mädels die nur eine Cute Voice haben, aber nicht die Optik dafür, dann machst du
Anime Girl, was, dann machst du Anime Girl Webcam Stream oder, weiß nicht wie man das
nennt, ja und wie gesagt ich hab da schon gesehen, dass es da Streams mit 8000 Leuten
und so gibt, ASMR Anime Grill, oh fuck jetzt gibt's aber hier Donation Overload, guck mal
in Streamen ein Video tut an wie man VTuber wird, das ist echt interessant, du brauchst
irgendwie, du wirst lachen, ich hab sowas schonmal geguckt, nämlich weil ich mich gewundert
hab wo diese ganzen Streams auf einmal herkommen in der Richtung, du brauchst ja sogar so eine
Art Motion Capturing Geschichte ne, ja, was es nicht alles gibt, was ist nicht, oh man,
das nennt man VTuber, ja hat er ja grad geschrieben, wisst ihr was Leute, du machst mir ein, easy,
easy, mach mir nen Avatar, nen VTuber, das mach ich, ach nee, ach mach dir mal, ich hab
verstanden, ich mach dir mal nen Avatar, ok Leute, sollen wir einen Vtube Keks machen,
wo sollen wir nen Vtube Keks machen, ich muss mir das echt angucken, das ist wahrscheinlich
richtig Paints Champ ja, ok, aber Fabian, Fabian, wenn ich den ersten Vtube Stream mache,
da musst du auch dabei sein, nein, nein, nein, kein Voice Changer, da musst du dir dann
auch nen Avatar machen, da musst du dir auch nen Avatar machen, und dann machen wir dann
ein Dual-Dual-Commentary-Stell als angehende VTuber, excellent, das Avatar Zeug ist gar
nicht so easy, kein Problem, Fabian, gar kein Problem, ich hab nen Pfeifer-Account, ich
hab nen Pfeifer-Account und lass das für 2,50€ irgendeinen Inder machen, und ich hab da
auch schon was gekauft, ich weiß auch prinzipiell wie das funktioniert, ich geh einfach auf
Pfeifer und lass mir was machen, Stonks, nee ich mach keinen Voice Changer, ich mach doch
auch keinen Porn-Stream, ich setz mich höchstens als Keks hin, wenn wir schon Pool am Start
haben, oh man, nicht dass du versehentlich dein Face revealst, weil die Software spackt,
oh fuck, nee ich glaube nicht, dass das funktioniert, ich glaube nicht, dass das richtig Overlaid
wird, sondern nur dass sich das Captured und dann den Avatar da draus quasi animiert, also
du kannst dich da glaub ich gar nicht liegen, du stellst jetzt, wenn der Keks einfach redet,
ich find die Idee lustig, ohne Scheiß, ich guck mir das echt mal an, ich find die Idee
witzig, ich mein ich werd mich nicht jeden Tag hier dann hinsetzen mit nem Keks-Avatar,
aber ich find die Idee geil, ich glaub ich mach das einfach mal, ich probier das mal
aus, das ist witzig, das muss ich mir mal angucken, ey das ist cool, guck mal hier wir
haben hier die richtigen, wir haben hier die richtigen, äh, äh, Bearbeitungs-Stell-Leute,
hä, warum steht denn immer in meinem Pool ne Handgranate, der Rest passt ja, aber muss
da ne Handgranate stehen oder ist das gar keine Handgranate, oder ist das ne Vase oder so,
das ist ne Vase, also, also ich werd, den Avatar, also ich muss, keine Ahnung wie man
den Avatar bastelt Fabian, aber da muss ich mal gucken, ich lasse das irgendeinen Fiverr
Inder machen, oder wer auch immer, muss ja kein Inder sein, aber Inder sind viele Inder
auf Fiverr, ok, ich speier das mal, probier mal aus, save, Desktop, neues Image, mal
gucken wie wir das da hinkriegen, planten wir das mal aus, oh was hab ich jetzt ausgeplantet,
ah, die Cuts, Moment, das lassen wir da, add Image, Desktop, oh Mist wie ist das, Back,
ah, yes, so und jetzt, und jetzt, muss noch, muss noch das Wasser spritzen, excellent, so
ist das perfekt, was hat's mit dem Poolaufsicht, na die ganzen Mädels, die aktuell auf Twitch
Poolstream machen, gib einfach mal Pool ein auf Twitch, du hast mittlerweile, irgendwie
abends, wenn du guckst, keine Ahnung, 50 Mädels mit den wirklich, also, wie soll ich
sagen, also, h-schärfsten, äh, Bekleidungs, quasi Streifen, die möglich sind, dass man
nix sieht, was Toss ist, gibt's auch Kerle, äh, ich hab letztens irgendwie nen Stream Fail
gesehen, da waren ein Kerle im Pool, ja, es gibt glaub ich auch vereinzelte Kerle, aber,
ich mein, du wärst ja quasi, wie gemacht für mit sowas mal anzufangen, easy money,
einfach, einfach Subgoals, Snapchat, Badewasser, ich mein, du hast ja wenigstens die Optik
für sowas, du kannst das easy machen, und es gibt, es gibt bestimmt genug, die sich
das gerne angucken würden, 100 pro, oh man, Poolstreaming, alter, Bademode, ja, stimmt,
Bademode, äh, sagt mal jetzt mal, Fabian, was ganz, was anderes, wollten wir nicht
eigentlich zu Weihnachten schon was aufnehmen, und, und haben dann aber irgendwie kurz vorher
gesagt, wir nehmen doch nix auf, weil's zu kurzfristig ist, und nach dem Stream sellt
man das Poolwasser, das ist auf jeden Fall ne Option, ja, das kann man auf jeden Fall
machen, ja, das ist nicht, nicht verkehrt, ja, wir sollten echt mal wieder was aufnehmen,
klassischer Laberstelz, da kommen die Leute dann wieder um die Ecke mit Witzen von vor
10 Jahren und fragen, wann die Sylvaner ihre Titten endlich zeigt, das ist immer, wenn
wir Videos zusammen aufnehmen, kommen die Leute da an den Start mit Dingern, die schon,
die schon quasi outdated sind seit 100 Jahren, ja, still waiting, ja, mittlerweile sind das
Boomer-Witze, ihr wisst, wie alt wir sind, ne, wir sind ja ungefähr gleich alt, dein
YouTube-Game ging nur drei Videos, ich hab letztens wieder mal auf den YouTube-Channel
geguckt, weil ich, weil ich so, quasi so bisschen, so bisschen innerlich post-chämt
habe und hab mir gedacht, hat er eigentlich noch mehr Videos gemacht oder nicht, und
dann bin ich draufgekommen, ne, hat er nicht, dabei hat man dich in Unterhose gesehen, also,
der Sprung von da zum Pool-Stream ist dann aber weit, wir sind echt Boomer, sag ich ja,
der Chat klaut mir das immer nicht, oh fuck, Fabian, ich hab meinen Account noch nicht
umgezogen, geht das noch, ich glaub, das geht bis Anfang Mai, ne, weil ich will, also,
ich bin ja zwar kein großer BDO-Grinder, aber dass er ganz weg ist, will ich auch nicht,
der ist glaub weg, ne, da stand was von Mai, oder, bis Ende Mai, ok, ok, passt ja, passt
ja, dann, dann zieh ich, dann zieh ich den, dann zieh ich den noch um, Season kommen
nicht, ja, das hab ich bei dir im Stream gehört, hab ich, das wär was, da hätt ich
ein bisschen mit Kreisel grind, einfach sinnlos ein bisschen Kreisel grind machen, da hätt
ich Bock drauf gehabt, ja, noch 50 Tage Zeit, wenn ich 50 Tage warte, ihr kennt mich, ähm,
dann mach ich das an Tag 49, und dann mach ichs nicht und dann ist der Account weg, richtig
sack, naja, Leute, ähm, muss ich mir jetzt noch irgendwas angucken, weil ihr habt mir
so viel Sachen geschickt, ich glaub, das kann ich mir mit alles gar nicht mehr angucken,
das, das soll ich, ok, das haben wir uns angeguckt, das fand ich nicht gut, genau, das fand ich
nicht so tolle, ähm, der Computer-Futzi, den fand ich auch nicht so tolle, was soll
ich mir sonst noch angucken, das hier, Tschüss, Alltag, hallo, Abwechslung, DevOps-Engineer-IT-System-Administrator,
ok, ich find das durchaus in Ordnung sogar, dass die beiden Sachen zusammenstehen, weil
man muss ja mal, man muss ja mal sehen, wie es ist, das, was heute DevOps-Engineer ist,
war früher IT-System-Administrator, also sprich, viele Leute, ähm, waren früher mal das und
sind heute das, ist ja bei mir genau das gleiche, das Archiv ist jetzt auf Shithub, excellent,
wie, das Archiv ist auf Shithub, nicht mehr hier, keiner schief mehr hier, ja gut, ne,
ne Anwendung auf, ne Anwendung auf GitHub bringt jetzt, den Leuten auch erstmal nicht so viel,
oder, ach so, das ist, ach sprich, das müssen wir, das ist ein older Prototype, ja aber gut,
das ist ja noch gar nicht fertig, was, hast du Onlyfans, äh, das ist geheim, das gibt's
erstmal 5 Subs, mein Onlyfans Link, ja Patreon, Patreon auch, Leute, ich hab mir überlegt,
ich muss ein bisschen mehr Sellout machen, ne, also ich muss auf YouTube auf jeden Fall
auch Abonnenten-Feature einrichten, Boomer müssen pennen, versteh ich voll und ganz,
ich bin auch schon müde, ja, bis denn, CU, und um nicht zu vergessen, Fabian, Fabian,
Fabian, bist noch da, bist noch da, ne, jetzt ist er schon weg, ey, das Demo, das ist nicht
schlecht, ach so, genau, also, das allerwichtigste, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte, weil wir
uns so lange schon im Discord nicht mehr gehört haben, ja, eigentlich wollte ich sagen, CU,
da wollte ich machen, das versteht jetzt keiner, mach nix, FaZe-Chef, so, jetzt bist du ein
Schlafgurt, was gut, also, wo sind wir stehen geblieben, ähm, die DevOps-Engineer-Geschichten,
ja, ihr müsst wissen, der Friseur und ich, wir waren früher Meister im nervigen Sounds
machen, das hat den Master-Crupper immer, glaub ich, ziemlich genervt, wir haben so
ziemlich alle dummen Sounds aus Games nachgemacht, so, vor Zeiten, also, wenn wir nicht, wenn
wir nicht aufgenommen haben, kennt ihr zum Beispiel noch den Witch-Sound aus Left4Dead,
das war die 360, das war die 360, Moment, Moment Fabian, du meinst, du meinst das hier,
du meinst das hier, nicht gegen die Wand, gegen meine Hand, ich hab immer, ich hab immer
so gemacht, mit dem Xbox-Controller, ja, ja, der Witch-Sound aus Left4Dead und mit so Sachen
haben wir den Master-Crupper früher immer genervt und irgendwann, und irgendwann haben
wir dem Casten dann erzählt, übrigens, wusstest du eigentlich, dass die Witch-Sounds aus
Left4Dead von uns gemacht wurden und dann meinte der Cast nur noch da drauf, was, wie,
so brain afk war das schon durch unser Gelaber, der hat uns überhaupt nicht mehr zugehört,
der hat einfach nur, der hat einfach nur irgendwas gesagt, dass wir ihn in Ruhe lassen, oh man,
so, jetzt gucken wir uns mal, jetzt gucken wir uns mal die Geschichte hier an, also Fabian,
bis denn, wir müssen mal eine Runde Laberstellens wieder machen, am nächsten, ja, geil gewesen,
ja, hätten wir BDO spielen können, aber wenn nicht funktioniert mit Seasons, sucked, was
ist denn nur mit Casten los, ja, das würde mich interessieren, was der so treibt grad,
was gecrapped wird, also, DevOps-Engineer, in Voll- oder Teilzeit, finde ich übrigens
eine coole Sache, wenn die gleich schon Teilzeit dabei schreiben, D2, oh ja, Diablo 2 wird
auf jeden Fall gespielt, Poggers, Teilzeit, für Teilzeit-Boomer wie mich ist das natürlich
super, dass man gleich sieht, es geht auch in Teilzeit, der Software-Markt ist ständig
in Bewegung, genau wie unser Entwickler, okay, übliche bla bla bla, am Anfang zur Verstärkung
des Fachbereichs Research und Development suchen wir flexible Denker und agile Macher,
Alter, was ein Ding wieder, flexible Denker und agile Macher quasi, schließlich kommt
der Erfolg der Baramundi-Software nicht von irgendwo, sondern zu 100% aus Deutschland,
dafür gestaltet man am Standort Augsburg, eingespielte Teams und Software-Entwickler
und Testern, Scrummastern, Product Owner und agile Coaches, die Software-Produkte, also
das ist für Peter Aguilet tatsächlich, echt, das wär was, das wär was, da könnt ihr sich
wohl fühlen drin, die Software-Produkte von morgen, das einzige, was uns dafür im Moment
fehlt, bist du, Chet, ihr fehlt den, hättet ihr das für möglich gehalten, aber gut, kann
ich verstehen, 150 plus IQ, Chet, wem fehlt der nicht, ja, optimieren, kontinuierlich
aber, okay, bla, bla, bla, neue Technologien, Continuous Integration, Continuous Delivery
Prozesse, Pringestein, ja gut, das ist normal, ja, Microsoft Azure DevOps, Docker, Kubernetes,
Hyper-V, ja, Teamworken, als Teil eines, oh, Safe, das ist das agile Ding, was ich immer
vergesse, was es heißt, da musste ich sogar im ersten Video nachgucken, ich vergesse immer,
was Safe ist, das ist auch so ein Agile System, ich vergesse es immer, Scaled Agile Framework,
ich vergesse immer, was es heißt, Hyper Agile, Chainlord, das ist, das E-Mode, das du gepostet
hast, das könnte man zu einem Wuppmonks machen, Wupps oder so, aber da müssten wir uns noch
ein bisschen überlegen, das brauchen wir noch so den letzten Schliff, da fehlt noch irgendwas,
da müssen wir mal, müssen wir mal im Discord uns mal Gedanken zu machen, weil so ein Wupps
E-Mode wäre schon cool, also jetzt kein, nicht dieses Wupps, sondern ein Wupp, so ein Monkers
mit Kicks, also, wenn es du agile Entwicklungsminuten bietest, Hilfestellenanfälle sind auch so,
ja gut, das ist mittlerweile auch normal, das sind halt alle Safe, Agile, I-Tills, Crumb-Driven,
also immer, was zockst du noch außer Battlefield 3, Battlefield 3 spiele ich nicht, weil Venice
ist dead und Passive X, da habe ich die letzten 2 Seasons nicht gespielt, also gerade nix,
kommunikativ sein, du stimmst dich und kommst hier, ok, blablabla, das ist also auch normal,
selbst die Notwendig-Umgebung, naja, ok, da ist jetzt eigentlich nix Schlimmes, das klingt
doch ganz normal und ok, ja, kann man doch eigentlich nix sagen, ist doch vollkommen
in Ordnung, wieder Kotgebashe irgendwann mal, ja das Problem ist, ich finde halt den normalen
Multiplayer nicht gut, ne, also weder der Black Ops Multiplayer, noch der Modern Warfare Multiplayer,
Venice ist tot, also Venice spielt keiner mehr, die hatten mal einen Memory Leak, dass
das Spiel gecrashed ist nach ein paar Runden und ich weiß nicht, ob sie den jemals gefixt
haben und seitdem spielt das keiner mehr, ne, also wenn du mit so Death Ops Sachen nix
am Hut hast, ist es vielleicht nicht das richtige, aber mal ganz im Ernst, das Death Ops ist
für viele einfach nur ein riesen Sammelgebiet, für alle möglichen Sachen, im Kern ist es
natürlich schon so, dass es hauptsächlich um, ob so Sachen wie Continuous Integration,
Continuous Delivery geht, um Bildtools, irgendwelche Automatisierungs-Tools, Infrastruktur-Automatisierungen,
automatisches Paketbilden, automatisches Server-Management, irgendwelche Orchestrierungsgeschichten,
halt um das Leben im Prinzip alle ein bisschen einfacher zu machen, je nachdem, wie viel
Ahnung du hast, ist das, auch wenn du jetzt noch nicht bei dir irgendwie Death Ops draufstehen
hast, auch kann das schon was für dich sein, ja, also kann ich jetzt natürlich schlecht
sagen.
Richtig schade drum, Venice spielt sich viel besser als Vanilla Battlefield.
Zehn Gründe für deinen Einstieg, komm in Ruhe an, welcome Frühstück, MonkaS, das klingt
so, als müsste man sich da mit ganz vielen seiner Mitmenschen auseinandersetzen, denkst
du, Node wird PHP irgendwann ablösen, nee, weder noch, das wird co-existieren, ich würd
mal sagen, die Node-Codebay, also insgesamt Node-Projekte steigen natürlich deutlich mehr
als die PHP-Projekte, aber ich glaub, PHP werden wir nie los, zumal man auch sagen muss,
dass PHP mit den passenden, also ich hab mal zum Beispiel was mit Laravel gemacht, das
war aber auch schon ein paar Jahre her, das ist schon durchaus erträglich, nee, ich krieg
keine Messages auf Discord, hab ich ausgeschaltet, vielleicht voll gespammt, du kannst mir, also
wenn du wirklich, wenn du da jetzt ganz scharf drauf bist, was ich was zu sage, und du das
nicht im Chat posten willst, kannst du mir das an die E-Mail-Adresse schreiben, an die
Business-E-Mail-Adresse, da guck ich mal rein, ey, das ist so, E-Mail ist das Ding schlechthin
für Kontakt in der Richtung, ist auch das Einzige, was die jeweiligen Plattformen unterstützen,
also das, das macht doch alles einen guten Eindruck hier, oh, da kann man es doch bewerben,
das klingt doch in Ordnung, so jetzt mal schnell hier rüber, was soll ich mir sonst noch angucken,
ich hab jetzt was, ich hab hier noch anders, ja,
Also es ist Schullogin, Login wie Einloggen oder Login wie Syntologe, ok es heißt Schullogin
tatsächlich, ja. MonkaS, die lacht uns aus. Ok, excellent. Tja, das ist schon mal eine äußerst
painschampig zu lesende Stellenanzeige. Boah, das ist ja grausam zu lesen. ZLSB, was ist
denn das ZLSB? Ah, das Zentrum für Lehrer, Bildung, Schule, das muss man natürlich
sagen. ZLSB, alles klar. Amministration, Weiterentwicklung, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla. Ok,
alles unwichtig, was hier am Anfang drin steht. Aufgaben, Weiterentwicklung, Programmierung,
Amministration, das Identitätsmanagementsystem Schullogin, Prüfung der Anbindung, weitere
interne und externe Angebote, Durchführung von automatischen Testprogrammierungen, Schnittstellen,
Erprobung von Kommunikations- und Kooperations... Denn übrigens, Proben ist auch so ein geiles
Stonkswort, das haben bei uns irgendwelche Prozessleute mittlerweile am Start, die sagen
nicht mehr, wir testen das, die sagen, die Verprobung hat begonnen. Kein Choke jetzt.
Wir haben begonnen mit der Verprobung, nicht, wir testen das jetzt, wir probieren das aus,
wir verproben nun. Das klingt excellent, ne? Das klingt aber eher Proben vielleicht, aber
was sollen denn Verproben überhaupt für ein Wort sein, Alter? Absprache zum Betrieb
mit dem Betreiber und weiteren externen Akteuren. Ok, klingt doch eigentlich alles vollkommen
normal. Wow. Man darf für das jetzt studiert haben, muss man. Oder gleichwertige Kenntnisse
und Erfahrungen, ja gut, passt. Einschlägige Berufserfahrung in der Softwareentwicklung
und dem Betrieb, größere Software-Systeme, Datenbank, Web-Anwendung. Das kann im Prinzip
alles sein. Für unterschiedliche Anwendungsgruppen, Offenheit, Ideenreichtung, hohe Belast... Ah,
da bin ich immer schon ein bisschen skeptisch, wenn sowas drin steht. Und operativ, hohe Belastbarkeit
und operative Umsetzungsstärke. Das heißt im Prinzip, man schafft viel, obwohl einem
alles auf den Sack geht. Ja, die sagen überhaupt nicht, um was es überhaupt geht, ne? Die
schreiben einfach nur blablabla. Man hat überhaupt keine Ahnung, um was es geht. Ja, ok, das übliche.
Da steht ja nichts. Da steht ja wirklich absolut nichts. Das ist echt eine dumme Stellenanzeige.
Da steht nichts. Was kriegt man eigentlich dafür? Steht da irgendwie links, links, was
man... Ah, bei vollen Nippeln... E11TVL, ok, so gucken wir mal, was es da gibt. Was, E11?
Ah, da kommen wir doch schon eher in die Region, was da abgeht. By the way, was sind das hier
für Stufen? Sind das Berufsjahre oder wie funktioniert das? Ich hab da keine Ahnung
davon. Ja, also das ist schon durchaus in Ordnung.
Oh fuck. Ernsthaft? Da musst du ja ewig dabei bleiben, dass das funktioniert. Also das heißt,
das bekommst du sofort, ne? So, nach zwei Jahren bekommst du das. Nach drei Jahren bekommst
du das. Also das heißt, ein Jahr, zwei Jahre, also bekommst du es nach zwei Jahren oder
im zweiten Jahr. Man sieht nix, ah, man sieht nix, weil der Keks davor ist, lull. Der Keks
spritzt davor. Aber Pool muss sein heutzutage. Also man kann auch mit mehr einsteigen, oder
was? Okay, aber das ist durchaus in Ordnung. Also da würde ich jetzt, könnte ich mir durchaus
vorstellen, das zu machen. Wobei, wenn ich den, ich mach den Fehler, ich mach den Fehler,
ich rechne das immer mal 14. Ich rechne das immer mal 14. Ich muss das ja mal 12 rechnen.
Ich guck mir immer Monatsgelder an und rechne die dann mal 14 auf Jahrhoch, damit ich das
mit uns vergleichen kann. Aber das stimmt ja nicht. In dem Fall musst du es mal 12 rechnen
und dann ist es doch, dann ist es doch nicht so, dann ist es durchaus okay, aber jetzt
nicht so der Hammer, ja. Das ist ein Standbild von der Katz, aber der Keks ist echt. Ja gut,
aber die Stellenausschreibung ist crap. Das soll ich mir nochmal angucken, okay, Sack.
Pulse Deck, Web Developer, Backend, JavaScript, MVD, Remote Work. Warum mal 14, weil es bei
uns 14 Monatsgelder gibt, deswegen hab ich mich schon so dran gewöhnt, dass ich immer
alles rechne, Monatsgelder mal 14. Ja, Changer, ich meld mich im Discord, können uns da was
überlegen. Das muss richtig MonkaSpanisch sein, der Keks. Ich bin mir noch nicht ganz
sicher, wie wir das machen am besten. Ich hoffe ich vergesse es nicht, du darfst mich
auch ruhig an-spammen im Discord, falls ich da bin, falls ich es vergessen sollte. So,
ah stimmt, im halben, egal was 50% ist, ja gut. Also, was haben, Sport Rocker. Was zum
Teufel ist Sport Rocker? Klingt nach Marketing-Geschwätze ohne was dahinter, aber zeig mal her. Vera
ist am Start, okay, die können schon mal nicht so schlecht sein. Ja, also das ist eine Seite,
wenn das Marketing-Leute designen, dann sieht das so aus. So, also, Sport Rocker ist das
einzige Portal für außergewöhnliches Ad-Crowdsourcing. Was ist eigentlich Ad-Cro-, also was, was,
was bedeutet das? Also sprich, das ist sowas wie Fiverr, oder was? Das ist sowas wie Fiverr,
nur für Anzeigen. Weil, weil die Erklärung check ich nicht. Also wir versuchen mal die
Erklärung zu verstehen, zu verstehen. Sport Rocker ist das einzigartige Portal für außergewöhnliches
Ad-Crowdsourcing, auf dem User bzw. Kreative, vielfältige, authentische Ads explizit vollständig
und briefingkonform für Marken, Produkte, Leistungen produzieren, bewerten und direkt
verbreiten. Also im Prinzip sowas wie Fiverr, nur für Ad-Anzeigen. Das heißt außergewöhnliches
Open Brand Marketing durch die Crowd, wirkungsvoll und hocheffizient. Moment, Moment, das ist
nicht agil, das kann schon mal nix taugen. 3 Monate und 17 Monate lang für den Sub, exquisite
Subscription. Moment, wo ist der Hyper-Subscriber? So, bla bla bla, wir sind Deutsche People,
Pioniere vom... Naja, gut. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so eine geile Auszeichnung ist von
irgendeinem, wenn man da irgendeinen Preis gewinnt, aber ok. Ausgezeichnet weiter effizient als
die üblichen Produkte, bla bla bla. Stichwort High Productive Cure... Was? Das ist doch
kein Stichwort, das ist ein Buzzword Satz Extrem. Stichwort, Stichwort. Highly Productive
Curated User Generated Advertising. Ach du Scheiße. Durch Videos, Fotos, Cinema Crafts,
Memes, Text, Bildanzeigen und Co. Ey, die sind nicht agil, fällt schon mal raus. So,
wir leben und lieben Win-Win-Situationen in allen Belangen. Unsere Basis hierfür ist
echte Wertschutze. Ok, was wollt ihr denn überhaupt? Deine einmalige Chance. Oh, 2.0 gibt's bald.
Spottrocker 2.0. Das größer und funktionaler ist, so wie mehr Features und mehr Möglichkeiten
für Videos. Alles klar. Und wird eine fulminante Neuheit. Und genau hier hast du jetzt die einmaligen
Optionen, von Anfang an dabei zu sein. Aber ich kann's kaum erwarten. Und das ganze Portal
kommt und sagt, ok. Das heißt, wir suchen dich als topfähigen, praktizierenden Webentwickler.
Wie wär's, wenn ihr einfach noch ein bisschen was reinschreibt, was ihr genau macht, beziehungsweise
was ihr genau wollt? Sprich dich aus Praxis für die Praxis. Was? Sprich, sprich quasi
sowas wie, wir wollen dich aus der Praxis für die Praxis. Damit als Full-Stack-Web-Developer
Backend JavaScript. Ja, was denn genau? Dein Einsatzort bundesweit im Homeoffice-Remote
war wichtig, dein ständiger Wohnsitz muss Deutschland sein. Also, ok. Also, was wollt
ich? Ich hoffe, die schreiben jetzt bald nochmal, was die haben wollen. Kurz gesagt, du bist
Macher und Tutor des neuen Portals. Das heißt, bla, bla, bla. Du kreierst durch den Konzept
für in den Entwicklungszug mit... Ey! Ey! Full-Stack heißt keine komplette IT-Abteilung.
Full-Stack heißt, sagen wir mal, ein Entwickler, der auch ein bisschen über den Tellerrand
guckt, was Server angeht, was Hosting angeht, was Technologie unten drunter angeht. Einer,
der schon potentiell zu allem ein bisschen was sagen kann und sich da auch insoweit
auskennt, dass er da gute Sachen auswählen, entscheiden, sonst wie kann. Aber das heißt
nicht, dass der zwangsläufig in der Tiefe auch alles macht und man in einer IT-Abteilung
einer Person hat. Du kreierst, durchdenkst, konzipierst, initiierst, entwickelst, dokumentierst,
testest, debauchst und co. Bis das komplette Portal steht und läuft. Ja, gut, die suchen
mich, weil anscheinend alle anderen weggerannt sind oder so. Oder wie darf man das verstehen?
Die darauf folgenden Pflege und Weiterentwicklung des Systems gehört natürlich auch noch dazu.
Dabei legst du besonders auf Code-Qualität, Sicherheit, Usability, Stabilität. Für
Usability sollte ich ehrlich gesagt als Full-Stack-Entwickler nicht selbst sorgen müssen, sondern diejenigen,
die das Interface machen bzw. mir irgendwie mal ein paar Rahmenbedingungen erstellen.
Stabilität, Zuverlässigkeit, Performance, Skalierbarkeit, Automatisierung, DevOps-Ansatz.
Okay, das Wort musste jetzt einfach nochmal rein anscheinend. Bezüglich der konkreten
Entwickler ist dann hauptsächlich das Backend mit allem. Ja, was denn jetzt? Eben haben
sie noch gesagt, sie brauchen einen Web-Entwickler. Oben schreiben sie, sie brauchen einen Web-Entwickler,
danach schreiben sie was, sie suchen einen Full-Stack-Web-Entwickler und jetzt sagen
sie, das ist dein Hauptjob, hauptsächlich das Backend mit Datenbanken, Micros, ja was
denn jetzt? Und nutzerfreundliche UI, das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn. Bezüglich
der konkreten Entwicklung ist dein Hauptjob jedoch das Backend mit all seinen Datenbanken,
mit allen seinen, wieso hat man 50 verschiedene oder was? Hat man eine DB2, eine Oracle, eine
MySQL, eine MongoDB, eine CouchDB und so oder was hat man da? Microservices, Schnittstellen
und natürlich einer benutzerfreundlichen UI? Also was ich unter einer benutzerfreundlichen
UI verstehe, verstehe beim administrieren von so einem Ding, sind ordentliche Kommando-Zeilen-Tools,
aber das verstehen die bestimmt nicht und natürlich benutzerfreundliche UI, aber das
macht man doch nicht alles selber. Dafür muss doch der jeweilige Anbieter das Services sorgen,
dass das Ding benutzerfreundliches UI hat. Ok, das muss ich, das ist eine geile Antwort,
die muss ich mir aufheben. Prinzipiell kümmerst du dich, also jetzt, Moment, was? Prinzipiell,
also ok, Prinzipiell ist rhetorisch, das können wir weglassen, also du kümmerst dich auch
um das Frontend, allerdings kannst du hierfür auch weitere Entwicklungskräfte einsetzen,
die du entsprechend steuerst. Ach, ich mache auch noch Teamleitung oder sowas, what the
hell, was zur, Sportrocker, Alter, was ist da los? Ihr seht nichts, ihr seht nichts, weißt
ihr was, genug Pool-Stream, wir machen mal kurz den Keks weg, Keks ist im Bildsch. Prinzipiell,
also hier kümmerst du dich, allerdings kannst du hierfür auch weitere Entwicklungskräfte
einsetzen, das bedeutet, dass ich soll jetzt, ich soll auf LinkedIn und mir noch ein paar
Leute, soll ich noch selbst ein paar Leute anheuern oder so und dann Teamleiter machen
für die, what the fuck, Alter, was zum, was haben die sich denn da wieder ausgedacht?
Ich muss mir das mal speichern, ich dachte sie das löschen, Alter, das ist geil, das
im nächsten video reinhauen
All das erfolgt insbesondere in enger abstimmung mit dem gründer und geschäft okay das heißt im endeffekt die tun so
Solltest du das alles machen alles entscheiden und und alles die ausdenken aber in wirklichkeit hast du permanent
Einen am start der dir sagt dass das nix taugt was du machst wahrscheinlich oder sagt ja nie hier aber muss es so da muss es so und da muss es hier
und so
Okay
Im übrigen bist du die zentralen ansprechpersonen allen web auch noch dabei easy
Ja genial
Etu
Das die sagen dass du nebenbei ach und übrigen übrigen im übrigen also das war ja jetzt easy als fack bisher ne also
Absolut easy übrigen im übrigen noch nebenbei noch so noch so bevor du rausgehst soll ich vielleicht noch sagen also
Du bist auch ansprechpartner für alles auch das wofür wir dich am prinzip nicht wirklich eingestellt haben aber du bist passt schon
Also du bist auch ansprechpartner für alles auch das wofür wir dich am prinzip nicht wirklich eingestellt haben aber du bist passt schon
Genau am besten machst du noch geschäftsführer dabei
Kurz gesagt tiefgehende praxis erfangen full stack back end was denn jetzt
In komplexen, modernen Web-Entfaces ist mir alles nicht archiv genug.
Sehr gute Kenntnis in der Backend-Entwicklung mit JavaScript.
Jetzt kommen sie endlich mal zum Punkt, was sie eigentlich wollen.
Node.js?
Nest?
Nest.js?
Ich kenne Nux.js?
Nest?
Ist Nest React?
Ist das React, Leute?
Nee, was ist das?
Ah, da ist das Bild.
Ach, das ist eine Node.js Web-Framework oder so quasi sowas wie X...
Denn Ruby on Rails für Express sowas in der Richtung, würde ich mal vermuten.
Okay, der Chat sagt, es taugt was.
Sehr gute Kenntnis in der Backend-Entwicklung mit JavaScript, sorry, JavaScript natürlich,
sowie Schnittstellen-Entwicklung, GraphQL, REST, WebSockets.
Gut, das ist quasi einmal das komplette Paket, ne?
Weil, viel mehr Technologien gibt es ja da als für Backend zu erstellen, dann auch wieder
nicht.
Hiermit hast du ja im Prinzip auch so ziemlich alles dann an API-Sachen abgedeckt, aber gut,
das passt schon zusammen.
Sehr gute Kenntnisse in der Datenbank-Modellierung bzw. mit Datenbank-Systemen wie PostgreSQL,
MySQL.
Ja gut, das sind ja mit all seinen Backends, die haben verschiedene Backends, mit all seinen
Datenbanken.
Also, da tut es nicht einfach nur ein Datenbank-System, das müssen schon fünf verschiedene sein.
Kenntnis in der Server-Administration, idealerweise im Aufbau von Cloud-Infrastruktur.
Alter, allein dafür könntest du eine Person abstellen, die das hauptberuflich macht und
sonst nichts, ne?
Jetzt mal ernsthaft, dafür kannst du eine Person locker hinstellen, die nur das macht.
Know-how in der Frontend-Entwicklung, Angular-React, jetzt wollen sie auf einmal noch Angular und
React, UI-Design, alles klar, ja gut, das ist klar, fließt in deutsch-englischen Wort
und Schrift, womit du Techniker und Nicht-Techniker abholst, ja ja, das träumen die, davon träumen
die Marketing- und Stonks-Leute immer, ja, von Technikern, die mit Nicht-Technikern
gut reden können.
Ich meine, wovon träumen die denn nachts?
Techniker sind nicht umsonst gute Techniker, weil sie von Technik Ahnung haben.
Wenn man 90% schön blumig redende Stonks-Leute haben will, dann sucht man halt bei Technikern
falsch.
Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite, das ist jetzt nicht, kann man auch nicht pauschal sagen,
also man kann sich das schon ein bisschen angewöhnen, auch mit Nicht-Technikern ganz
gut zu gehen.
Ich muss sagen, das ist echt was, womit mir die Videos, die ich gemacht habe auf YouTube
tatsächlich ein bisschen geholfen haben, weil ich habe ja schon ein paar Technik-Videos
gemacht, wo man auch die Sachen so erklären muss, dass das nicht unbedingt jetzt so technisch
vorgebildete Leute verstehen und das hat tatsächlich was gebracht, ja, also das ist nicht verkehrt
auch Nicht-Techniker zu was erklären zu können.
Okay, eine schnelle und, was für ein Teil, eine schnelle und integrative Auffassungsgabe.
Ich hab legit, also erst hab absolut keine Ahnung, was sie damit meinen.
Was ist denn eine integrative Auffassungsgabe?
Gut merken können?
Nee, das ist einfach irgendwas, was cool klingt, die wissen selbst nicht, was sie da schreiben.
Äh, sprich, die Fähigkeiten, Einzelheiten, was die Fähigkeiten, Einzelheiten und Zusammenhänge
schnell zu verstehen, komplex zu denken, aber darf eben bestenfalls einfangen, blablabla,
eine eigenverantwortliche, konstruktive Einstellungs- und Verhaltensweise, strukturiert, lösungsorientiert,
effizient, pragmatisch, mitdenken, kreativ, unternehmerisch, zupackend, proaktiv, engagiert,
selbstorganisiert, selbstreflektiv, loyal, unvertrauenswürdig ist, loyal, loyal, loyal,
loyal, also sprich, man soll auch noch sagen, das ist der beste Laden überhaupt, ich bin
dankbar bei euch, arbeiten zu dürfen, unvertrauenswürdig ist und durchweg bestmöglich Ergebnis zeitnah
erzielen will.
Natürlich, natürlich, das ist dann so die Geschichte, so nach dem Motto, ähm, wie lang
brauchen sie dafür?
Ja, äh, vier Wochen, sie haben nicht so viel Zeit, ich machs in zwei, oder wie stellen
die sich das vor?
Kamen die Anzeigen zum ersten April, ja anscheinend, es hört ja nicht mal auf, ok die Vorteile,
die Vorteile interessieren mich jetzt echt, weil das muss schon eines der geilsten Läden
ever sein, dass man das macht, also, die einmalige Chance ein einzigartiges, hochfunktionales
Portal zu schaffen, von Grund auf zu entwickeln und damit perspektivische, technische Leitungsposition
im Unternehmen komplett einzeln, ich bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher, ob das so ein großer
Vorteil für mich ist, ist das ein Vorteil für mich?
Ich weiß nicht, das ist erstmal ein Vorteil für die, oder?
Ein junges Unternehmen, das du maßgeblich mitgestalten kannst und dabei eine Kultur
an den Tag legst, die geprägt ist von echter Wertschätzung, Konstruktivität, Fairness,
Vertrauen, Positivität und Humor.
Das kann tatsächlich sein, dass die, das ist bestimmt so ein Laden, das besteht aus
3 Leuten oder 4 Leuten oder so und die kennen sich alle aus dem Studium und die sind wahrscheinlich
wirklich voll dicke, ja, wenn die, wenn die dich, wenn die, ohne Scheiß Aristromat, das
habe ich mir auch gerade gesagt, dann sollen sie dir Anteile an der Firma geben, wenn die
wollen, dass du den Kram für lau machst, gut, von Geld, von Gehalt steht ja da gar
nix, ja?
Ein unbefristeter Arbeitsvertrag für eine 100% Position mit sehr flexib...
Okay, die Ergebnisse und Deadlines zählen, einem Attrakt, okay, das schreiben alle, das
schreiben einfach alle, habt ihr jemals schon eine Stellenanzeige gesehen, wo drin stand
unterdurchschnittliches Gehalt, also die schreiben alle ein attraktives Gehalt, wöchentlich
mehrfach Essensgutschein, okay, es ist nicht schlecht, ja, und 30 Tagen Urlaub plus bezahlt
im Sonderurlaub bei Bedarf, so wie weit, ja, okay, ist relativ normal, ich glaube gesetzlich
vorgeschrieben sind nur was, 26, aber 30 ist relativ normal, Remotewerk, das heißt an
technisch ausgestatteter Arbeitsplatz, bei dem haben wir natürlich bloß ausgiebige
Einarbeitung, das heißt die schenken, was heißt die schenken mir, das ist das falsche
Wort, ich mach dafür schon, das heißt die stellen mir oder geben mir einen ordentlichen
Desktop-PC für daheim oder was, natürlich bloß ausgiebige Einarbeitung, tja, wer mich
einarbeitet, der andere Mitarbeiter, der noch da ist, von zwei, anders gesagt Vielfalt und
Vielspiel, okay, also, dass man sich da bewirbt, das ist so ein bisschen wie das Cloud-Cameleon,
weiß nicht ob einer das Cloud-Cameleon aus dem letzten Video noch kennt, das ist so was
wirklich für die jungen Start-Up Leute, die eventuell da mal Millionär mit werden wollen,
wenn es um die Sushi-Decke geht oder so, sofern du irgendwelche Anteile überhaupt bekommst,
in was wird man da eingearbeitet, ja stimmt, eigentlich macht man hier alles, die Einarbeitung
bedeutet, dann guck mal, so lockst du dich per VPN ein und jetzt fang mal an, Deadline
in einer Woche, weil wir haben ja gehören, Deadlines zählen, so ungefähr wird das wahrscheinlich
sein, aber nice Stellenanzeige, was hab ich denn hier sonst noch, ich guck mal ganz schnell
durch, das hab ich, das hab ich, C++-Entwickler-E-Git, okay, also immer, das kann ich mir jetzt
ja mal angucken, da haben wir noch Projektleiter, Schullogin, das hatten wir doch grad schon
mal, das anraten wir auch schon, das hatten wir auch schon, okay, ich glaub ich hab sonst
nix mehr auf, ne, alles klar, ich hab alles, gut, weil ich muss jetzt off Leute, Dankeschön
für die ganzen Subs heute, war sehr nice, dass ihr alle am Start wart und ich seh das
Poolstream-Meter scheint zu ziehen, wir machen jetzt öfters Poolstream, in welche Richtung
würdest du gehen, wenn du nur das Gehalt maximieren willst, keine Ahnung, hab ich mir
nie Gedanken drüber gemacht, da würd ich wahrscheinlich mich konsulten lassen für
irgendwelche Stonks-Geschichten, die grad angesagt sind, was schätzt ihr, wie viel
das Gehalt ist, ehrlich gesagt, bei diesem Startup-Ding, bei diesem Startup-Ding geh
ich mal davon aus, dass du so gut wie nichts an Gehalt bekommst und dich irgendwie anders
locken wollen, wahrscheinlich können sich das gerne leisten, jemanden ordentlich zu
bezahlen.
Alles klar, wir sehen uns, bis denn, see you, macht's gut.